Oh, sweet. Jesus. Is this real?
Is this really happening? Yes.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
We go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight
and during the code Rogan sent me,
you will get 15% off.
Number one sex toy for mine.
There's like some sort of 15%
off sale it's going on right now.
So I don't know if it gives you 30% off.
I don't think that works that way.
I think you only allowed
to use one coupon.
I don't want people to go brook to
solid product folks. Go get one.
You know you're going to masturbate.
This is better.
Holla and then save a little money too.
But it's a solid product. And the company,
the good people, uh, were also brought
to you by [inaudible] dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain. I'm going to give
every last mile for brand Lynn today.
Show him what the fuck is up.
You might blow up.
It might change his whole attitude
about life. Um, we also make new mood,
which is a five HTP and l Tryptophan,
serotonin boosting supplements, good
stuff for you. All healthy stuff.
All of it is a, if you, if you don't
know what nootropics are pleased, Google,
Google the subject.
It's a fascinating subject.
Don't just go out and buy some Alpha
brain. Look at all the pros and cons. I,
there's not too many cons,
but we address all of it at
[inaudible] dot com there's um, uh,
there's a whole page dedicated to the
research behind all the nootropics.
We also have for the first order,
when you buy things,
it's a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return anything.
No one's trying to rip you off.
This is all stuff that I use is all stuff
that I use before I was selling it. Um,
I'm, I'm a firm believer in
vitamins and nutrition and health.
It's very important. It's
boring as fuck, man. Right?
I don't want to eat kale
shakes in the morning.
I'd rather have like some leftover
spare ribs or a, a protein shake with,
you know, some, something
delicious. But I do,
and I do take vitamins and I do
feel a difference. I've gone, I've,
I've experimented, I've tried no
vitamins, eat like shit. This is not good.
There's a big difference
between how your body performs,
how your mind performance.
For me,
that's the big one and this
is where nootropics come in.
Nootropics are really all about
enhancing cognitive function.
There's a bunch of other companies that
do a neutral big besides us. Go Do.
There's not, there's no, you know,
it's not that ours are better
than anybody else's. Ours is very,
very complete and very balanced and
very complex and some of them aren't as
aren't as complex, but there's a lot
of great ones out there. So Google it,
check it out.
Remember first order,
if you're not into it 30% off or
rather the first 30 pills rather,
you get 100% off.
You don't even have to send it in.
Just tell us it's sucks and
we'll say, sorry. All right.
No one's trying to rip you off a checkout.
There's,
there's also a shroom tech
sport and shroom tech immune,
two different mushroom based
supplements that do different things.
Shroom tech sport is great for
endurance and it's great for um, it's a,
it's great for energy.
It's really a crazy drug that was
actually discovered by people live in high
altitudes. It's just crazy.
Mushroom is quarter seps mushroom
and a bunch of other things that are
in there as well to to enhance, uh,
energy and endurance.
It gives you a little boost,
get a lot of [inaudible] 12 and
[inaudible] as well. And uh, that's it.
So go check that shit out.
And soon kettlebells,
kettlebells are almost here
within a couple of weeks.
Dude, I can't, I can't tell,
don't say anything about that one yet.
No. But um, the, uh, the regular ones,
we're going to have the cheap, we're
going to have not cheap, high quality,
best quality available,
but they're going to be inexpensive.
We're trying to make kettle
bells as cheap as possible,
but the best quality possible and only
sell it on the Internet and they see if
you,
if you can work out a deal with shipping,
I think we can make them very reasonable
because I think everybody's trying to
make money. You should make them smell
like blueberries or something. Great.
So that's working out. It smells like
vanilla. Doesn't help dudes, Bro.
That only helps you. That would help
you sit down and just start smelling.
All is working out, but it
smelled like vanilla. Come here.
If you'd call your girlfriend, honey,
come here. It smells like vanilla.
Sure. It's relaxing now.
He's in that a real thing. I,
yeah, but I don't think you want to be
relaxed while you're fucking Thrones with
kettle bells around.
Sun might let one go and throw it through
fucking wall or something. Start a cod.
Dan Electrical fire. Be careful.
Kettlebells would be very careful.
You have to know what the fuck you're
doing. Start Light. They're tough to do.
One 35 pounds. I'm a manly
man. Okay. And one 35 pounders.
A fucking serious workout.
There's a lot of them is a
extreme kettlebell cardio
workout that this guy put
out.
I forget who sells a video on dragon
door.com it's a great workout video and
this fucking guy does it all with one
35 pound kettle bell and you're dying by
the end of it man. Its brutality. So,
uh, that's, that's the next level.
All right,
bitches ever last is here.
He's going to play some music when
I have some fun kids. Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
[inaudible]
what happened was all that speed thing
I was playing around while you're
experimenting with you fucking freaky.
One of my good friends
in the music business,
one of the coolest motherfuckers I know
and one of the dudes that, you know,
when I think about like wow,
I'm friends, whatever the last,
it might not be a big deal to you cause
you're Everlast but when I was a fan of
house of pain, you know, when I first
moved to California, you know, it's,
to me it's just cool as fuck to
sit here and carry it with you.
I appreciate that man. Ay,
Yo, I got to also say, man,
last time I came over here,
we joked around about my Twitter.
There was like 6,000 people on it,
man.
There's like 16,000
now and I swear to God,
at least nine of those 10,000 came
straight from this show. I'm sure.
Well they didn't know. You know,
you're, it's, Oh gee. Everlast folks,
if those of you are looking for them,
cause I'm sure there's about a fake
mountains. I don't know. I don't, I I,
there must be, there's, there's a whole
bunch that it's hard finding someone on,
on, on Twitter. That's correct.
It's a real person actually got one of
those little check marks recently. Me.
I'm actually
mean now. Yeah, that's
tricky. You got to get those.
I look for the most positive
munch of people I've ever seen.
The from the Joe Rogan podcast podcasts.
You know, it's crazy, isn't it?
I was waiting for like, you
suck you're in. And I was like,
you know, I was, inevitably someone asks,
it wasn't none of that. It was crazy.
Amazingly Nice. It's the craziest
group of people. Uh, you know,
I had a guy came up to me to this show
this weekend and the dude was actually
crying. He had tears in his eyes and
he said that one of our podcasts will,
we're me and Brian Cowen,
we're talking about what's wrong
with you when you're a hater,
what it's really all about.
It's really all about this being
dissatisfied with yourself.
And then you look at someone and you try
to chop them down or you try to attack
the attack their weaknesses
or find their flaws.
But really what most of that
is comes from is a real,
a feeling of unease about your own life.
And absolutely it's all of it.
And this guy said that
it changed his life.
He said he literally stopped
behaving that way. He goes,
I realize what I was doing because I
realize what I was doing right there.
Cause I never, he goes,
I was just an asshole.
I didn't even know why I was an asshole.
I couldn't help being an asshole.
He goes,
but just spelling that out that it was
really all just me being frustrated about
myself. He goes, I couldn't see
that without you pointing it out.
But now I see it so clear. It's
changed my life. He's like,
it just opened the door that I can
never shut again. In any case, Dan,
he gave me a little tongue reached,
even don't realize you're,
your brain is extremely kind. Yeah. If
there's something that's bothering it,
it'll tuck it behind anything it can and
just tell you to ignore it. Yeah. Yeah.
And sometimes it's easy to just moving
a chair out the way and be like, Homey,
look, yeah, that's why you're
upset. The did you wrong? You know,
are almost always right.
The mind is incredibly complex and
none of us have a guidebook for it.
That's a real problem.
Nobody really, you know,
you can join a religion or you could join
us, you know, a cult or maybe, you know,
become a monk or something and
they give you some guidelines.
You could do it their way, but that
might not be the way you know, it's the,
the way is your way could be different
than I ways. A lot of Goddamn way.
A lot of ways.
But there's principles that you need to
get through like truth and honesty and
kindness. They sound weak. You know,
we talked about this last time that it
takes a lot of strength to be a loving
person, to just be open and loving. You
have to expose yourself and it sounds,
you know, the insecure people don't,
don't want to think like that.
They want to think there's something
wrong with them while you fucking queer.
What are you talking love?
You know, that's ridiculous.
You don't want more love in your life.
Everybody should want more love.
It doesn't mean you're weak.
It doesn't mean your wife's and usually
more than anybody else. Yeah, I know.
Almost always then they don't know
that everybody can see it. You know?
Cause I've been that dude.
I've been that angry dude and didn't
know that everybody could see like,
what the fuck is wrong with you, man? Why
you so tightly wound? Why? Why? You know,
why are you looking at smack people?
What the fuck is that all about? Well,
it's always some shit that has almost
nothing to do with what's going on right
in front of you. Yeah. I
mean, shit, I'm 42 man,
and I've probably only figured
it out nine months ago.
I think I figured it out last
week. I don't know, man. I
take a, it comes and goes.
I think that, uh, any,
any real feeling of
figuring anything out to me,
it's always like real fleeting and I
never feel confident enough to even say I
figured out ever. You know, it's
always, to me, it's always just, I'm,
I'm just trying to keep my fucking
head above water like everybody else.
Just trying to not only retain,
maintain, be nice and joy.
There's no mastery of this fucking
thing. This is a ride, right?
We're on top of a fucking
seven mile high wave man.
Just because the boat is turn the correct
direction doesn't mean we have any
control of this. Fuck. You know, you get
a good no, no control of this crazy life.
You just gotta enjoy.
Try to ride that wave as best you can
and try to do the best you can to enhance
your environment and enjoy what you've
got. Yeah. Enhance your environment.
Hence your friendships, you
know. Right. The absolutely.
That sounds like a Goddamn
Everlast song is, you know,
I'm gonna make you cry today man.
I bet you well,
you were making me cry when
you're warming up, man.
I had to go out and take a shit.
I was like,
I might have to drop some weight here.
This is too good.
What do you got for us, ma'am? Um,
I don't you want me to just get down
whatever you want to do. Are we ready?
We ready? Did we have one of my favorite
artists and a guitar in the room, man.
Yeah, man, get down. Get down. We can
always talk. It'd be fun. You know
[inaudible]
Salvin south been done was
battles one sour grapes,
sweet van.
Heaven starts Radware hill
and she was young 17 she bell.
So sob shit smells so clean.
Her aim was true.
Her heart was pure.
So the day that a daddy
walked out the door,
she's looking fo man in so much my Maha
by her Uncle Sam sent him off to
whoa
little Miss America now [inaudible] she
had the Barbie rat z channel sell her
story.
Sko random movie.
[inaudible] loom is America.
When did you get that scar?
Desert.
Sun blazing sand loving
Maha gun in my hand to lay
killed the man,
mortal Kombat and hand
saw man Q watchmen die.
So minutes has did.
I can't cry 18 months
since I've seen home.
I'll get up purple hot get a GI loan.
Let's see.
God blesses zero chow with the zone.
I'll go to Dan,
the dog alone,
Miss America and now that you glory,
she didn't have the Fab ride.
See you trying to sell his story.
Snow random movie.
She won't will be your style.
Zoom in America.
Did you get this cow back at home?
It's kind of strange. Ain't
nothing happening. Nothing changed.
Same old rules. Same Old game. Instead,
I'm haunted man named our friends.
Left me hang the wayso
heavy on Maine and not,
I miss going now to home show
the desert and mile long haul coal,
little Miss America.
And now Leo glow snap the Pob.
Ratzy Charles sell stories.
The moon
will be a staff.
There's Mary,
did you get this gal?
Where did you get that Skype?
Where did you get there Scott?
Wait,
did you get [inaudible]
okay.
Did he do that was heavy.
Hey Damn,
that was great.
That's heavy. Wrote that. Uh, uh,
when I went over to play for the boys
and our wreck, that must've been a trip.
I've, uh, I haven't been over there,
but I've hung out with a lot of those
guys on the basis when we do UFC shows,
military shows, man, fucking tough
life, man. Different breed of folk, man.
Yeah. God bless him. And we
wouldn't exist without them. Yeah.
We wouldn't exist without them.
I just don't like the people that are
putting them in places that aren't
absolutely. Well, I
mean,
I was brought over there and like I had
just released an album that was very
vehemently making statements against
like the administration and, and yeah.
And the war. But it, when
I was invited over there,
mmm.
Uh, you know, nope. They
didn't ask me about any written
out. And I, and I really,
you know,
I look at is most of these cats was
trying to get some college money and said,
you know,
I believe in something too.
Well that's what it used to be. I mean,
that's when, when Pat Tillman signed up,
that's what he did. He left the NFL.
Yeah. He was like, you know what,
I believe in this. This is real. You
know, our country's being attacked.
Then when he got over there, he was one
of the biggest critics of the war ever.
Once he got over there, him
and his brother, I mean his,
his brother doesn't even believe
it was friendly fire. Yeah. It was,
brother thinks they had him killed, I
believe and own that. And He, I mean,
they covered up this whole story
about friendly fire, you know? Yeah.
They pretend to remember died in war,
you know, by the time he was over there,
he just, he realized what a cluster fuck
it was. The whole thing is a mess, man.
It's uh, the people behind it though,
the people that you know, are,
we're willing to sign up and beat and
be heroes and really go and fight the
enemy in their mind. I mean, that's an
incredibly brave thing. And then this,
which is the most fucked up thing about
it is the idea that brave people get
manipulated
in the, in the name of
money. And I was, you know,
what it was shocking to me was how
young these cats were and how much
responsibility,
like carried on their shoulders.
And I thought about myself at 22 or 24 in,
this guy's running a squad of
tanks and I was like, you know,
you know, probably passed
out drunk in a bar, so sure.
You know what I mean? Triple. It was
like, you know, you've just given do,
I went out there and there they were. I
mean, it was like the most appreciative.
Like you, Dave, thank you so much.
Just for going unused. Just bananas.
I was like, I was, I was privileged
to going. I'd go back in a heartbeat.
She's so scary to be over there.
Let's go.
So scary to be in such a fucked up
place in the world. It's, you know,
most people that live in this
side live in Nice cities,
drive nice cars, you know, exist
in a peaceful state of harmony.
We're barely even aware that there's
some people that mostly financially and
fortunate at this point,
mostly just not a lot of
fucking opportunities where
they live at this point and
they're getting shipped off to some crazy
country on the other side of the world
is just filled with death and despair.
Like most people don't even know. Like,
you know this guy that snapped recently
and kill those people in Afghanistan.
You don't have a story. Hey Dude, like
three tours, tours. Not only that,
but he thought he was gonna
get off combat duty. They were,
they were dangling it over his head. He
was losing his house back home. And I'm,
you know, I'm not making any excuses
for this guy, but the day of his,
he watched one of his friends
get his legs blown off. Well,
and then I guess he just snapped. He
doesn't even remember it. He went where?
He says he doesn't remember it. Who
knows? But what did they, they're,
they manipulate the fuck out of these
people, man. I know what do to Ed?
Only 20 days left on a 20 year bid.
What? The Army Reserve and then with
20 days left, he was going to retire.
They sent him to Iraq for a year
and a half. They can just do that.
They send them back again to,
and once they send you once,
they can send you again, like you
literally worked for them forever.
You cannot quit. There is no tie.
They somewhere in the day for sure.
Habitation option. That's
insanity. And option B, what out?
The fact that we allow that man, that's
really fucked up. That's, that's uh,
that's uh, I'll tell you like this, I'm
honestly, you know, and if I was young,
I'd still be saying this,
you know, I ain't saying it
cause I'm past whatever age,
but I think to a certain degree
it should be you turn 18,
you want to like have certain
privileges in this country,
you should go do your two years service.
And you know what I mean?
Change a lot of Shit I'll tell you
which cause yeah, cause every senate,
his kid would be in there,
every,
every governor and the residents kid would
have to do it. It's, you know, you know,
but that'll never happen. You're
right. Yeah. You know, uh,
I think in principle then we'd have
a standing army at all times of what,
15 million people? Christ
more than that. Right.
And they know how many young people do we
have of that. Yeah. I would probably be,
what do we have now?
I bet it's probably 15 million now.
How many people are in the army?
Seven.
A number of US military.
How many times have you been over there?
A once,
but I'll go back any day now
while you like me have a daughter,
doesn't that uh, that's when you
see like dudes who have daughters.
My wife wasn't about you being over there
am I believe my wife was pregnant when
I went. Wow. Yeah.
You know, it's weird, Joe, that you, uh, I
was listening to some old Howard Stern's.
I don't really have you been listening
to the Kinison and shit and somebody said
something on the Howard stern show
and he was like, is that true?
But he didn't have a computer to like
go like how many people in the military?
So I was just thinking like, how weird
is that? Like Howard had no idea.
There was no way for him to check that
at all. So you just pretty much was like,
all right,
I guess I have to believe this.
You can talk all kinds of crazy
shit back then. Yeah. Yeah.
That's good shit though.
All Week he's having Sam Kinison on.
Yeah, I listened to it today.
It's crazy. From 1988. It's weird.
You know, it's when I first
started doing comedy. Yeah.
And because of Sam Kennison too.
There was the first dude that I
ever heard that I was like, Whoa,
that's comedy too. Yeah. That was crazy.
I remember when the first time I saw him,
it was, it was a shock. It was
like, wow, that's new. Yeah.
That to changed the whole
game. He changed comedy, man.
He went hard on the religious
stuff at a time when that was,
and he got away with it too, because
he was a former preacher that, yeah.
The other way is like crazy.
That was, he was, he was classic.
Does he have a dog? A daughter's
right? Or does he have any
I, yeah. Well he has him with his friend's
wife. Do you know that whole story?
Yeah, I don't think so.
You know, story. Um,
he had a good fuck.
I'm blanking on the dude's name now.
The dude with a shaved head.
Oh my goodness. Oh, shut up.
No fuck.
I can't believe I'm Carlo.
Carlo was his buddy and his road partner.
He opened for Kennison on the road and
apparently Kinison was banging his wife
and he didn't even know about it.
And he had a kid with this chick
and he thought it was his kid.
It's kinnisons kid.
So the whole time he's been raising
this kid thinking it was his,
it was his best friend. His best
friend went up shithead. Wow.
Banging his friend's wife. Wow.
That'll end that without a condom.
You fucking dirty bitch.
He was crazy. You know,
they said with Kennison it was a head
injury that changed his whole life.
He was a kid.
He got hit by a truck,
said completely changed his personality
by completely became a totally different
person. We can reckless and
crazy and loud wild for that.
It was like a regular calm
sort of a peaceful kid.
Maybe he liked, didn't see another side
and just realize, decided it was a,
was he was going ham could be right.
Yeah.
He crossed over for a second or I think
it's just head injuries in general are
fucking really bad for you. You know,
getting, getting your head fuck stops.
Not good for some people it changes their
personality. I've heard of dudes that,
uh, became depressed. They, uh,
they got just knocked out once and
then they started getting like band
depression like all the time. Like real
had a really hard time being happy.
Well just one concussion, you
know, golf ball that ahead.
I know dude was fucked up by a
golf ball that said for six months.
He was just a mess. Six months,
man. That's crazy man. Yeah.
Yeah. And that's another thing that's
going on with these soldiers. You know,
the UFC has done, uh, a few of these,
a fight for the troops for the head
injury, traumatic brain injury. Yeah.
I did like I'm one of those little essays
for it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's a,
that's some shit that's happening
now. Like last, before it closed,
I actually did a visit at Walter Reed
where they have all the cats, you know,
hit got hit with the
IUD. Is that, that, that,
that will change your perspective because
there's dudes there with literally
half a body. Yeah. And talking like I
wish I could go back cause I got home,
he's there and I need, you
know, like they, it's crazy.
I'm kid got two artificial legs talking
about he's getting ready to, you know,
join the DEA. Wow. Like,
you know, some crazy shit.
Don't make your problems seem
real, real small. You know?
I think that sense of comradery that a
lot of those guys have with each other
too. It hits, it hits a
crazy level, you know,
it hits a level that other than
the average person has civilian,
it's probably never going to experience
will the level of panic and fear and
emotion in a moment of death is, you
know, and then you're sharing it.
So whatever secrets you got it, you
know it's going to come to the service.
Not necessarily like you're going to
yell out your secrets, I'm saying,
but if you're a guy who's gone cry while
you're fighting or were they all that's
coming out and yeah, you know, is going,
you're going to bond
over that kind of shit.
I would imagine that's why fight camps
are always so close to, you know, like a,
an MMA fight, camp shore martial
arts schools. Oh that shit you,
you experienced something
really scary together. You know,
it's not as scary as war, but any,
anything. What's the old saying?
There's no atheists in foxholes,
man.
Indeed. Indeed. So what else
you got for us, man? Eight.
Somebody put a request in that. I agree
with 100% I love your fucking cover.
A Fulsom prison brews. I'll get
there, I'll kill you. It won't happen.
It won't have the lead like dude dude,
dude dude dude cause I only got one at a
time so Brian can do it with his mouth.
Kind of talking about a subject I'm, I'm
writing from, my dad's got a guitar here.
I'm gonna do this one. This
one. This one's costing you
imagine some of us spray.
Okay.
[inaudible]
some of us,
some of the sand,
some of us just don't
know where to being gay.
Guilty pleasures. Gotcha.
Take and some bags.
Measure Baluzi nephew in.
Some of us pray.
Some of us,
some of us live Paolo
bad.
Some of us just laugh
at the others who cry.
Broken hearted. Saba who gotcha.
Banking, lacking, renewed.
And some of us can look each other when,
yeah.
Some of the live stat.
Some of us get,
some of us stay
and some of it's just Latin beds.
We made
hops out sounding buster here,
Deb.
Thank near everybody you trust to here.
It can always fix everything.
You bring
some of this guilt.
Some of us take,
some of us pre sell the sand.
Most of us just don't know where to begin.
It's guilty hearted pledges.
Got Bacon,
some unorthodox magic.
Can't help it.
Or who's eating if you win
some some sin.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
wow.
First Time I ever done that one
life. Really? Yup. Alright, hold on,
let me turn it again. Okay.
Am I back? There we go.
That's the first time you've ever
done in my life. Really? Yeah. Wow.
That's awesome. I'm monitoring dude.
That's bad ass. I love that song.
Do you sometimes forget like,
uh,
did that lyrics are the thing and you
have to kind of make shit up on the fly.
Like, oh, like, oh, I just
fucked up at Coursera.
I would kind of bring it back like
[inaudible] which, you know, I was still,
I was taught by some cats that,
that showed me along the way.
If you mess up on the guitar, you know,
do it again. Oh, just like go do it again.
Okay. I look, make it look like
you're meant to do it kind of thing.
You know what I mean? Or just own it.
Own it and keep it moving. You know?
I'll be honest,
if I have a mess up terribly,
I'll stop doing it. I was doing it shows
the whole hold up man. Ah, this, yeah,
that sucks right there.
I just really chopped that to hell.
So we're going to start over and what they
get right. Is there a time limit? Like,
yeah. If it's like 30 seconds left
in this song, you're obviously,
you're probably not going to do that.
I mean, it would have to be something.
It would have to be something that
disturbed my groove enough. Right.
Where I couldn't stop thinking
about it, you know? Yeah.
Which after 20 some odd years, it would
take a pretty big bump in the road.
You know, you've been on
the road like crazy lately,
right? You've been just doing?
Yeah,
I'm on a new new,
you know, just, I love playing music man.
We've been doing a combo of live
band stuff and I'd just, like I said,
I just did a run of acoustic shows
and I really enjoyed it. And you know,
what did you do? Acoustic? You just,
you and the guitar. That's it. Um,
sometimes I'll have another guitar guy
sitting with me to cover like lead parts
for the, you know, certain songs
and little counter, you know,
picking while I'm strumming kind of thing.
Just to add to the song a little bit,
I was just in Louisville
when we were there.
The University of, of Kentucky is
playing the University of Louisville.
Oh, basketball game. That's like the
worst day ever day. Hate each other.
Apparently they have like a
civil war going on.
And so dude,
you got to look at these pictures and
I'm Polish it up cause it's ridiculous.
These dumb motherfuckers, they got
all their photos. These kids ride it,
Kentucky wins. But students
lose and basketball riot photos.
It's on
wired.com Kentucky wins.
But students lose in basketball.
Rive photos that got to see this shit.
These stupid mother fuckers, they're all,
their pictures are all on the Internet.
They don't know anymore. This is not
the same world that seventies yeah.
You kept this right. Reflect
on like man, like you.
I used to love shows like
deadwood and I'd be like, man,
if I lived in the 18th something's man
I would been at shooting a motherfucker
cat dog aisle.
It is dude.
Like totally you get away
with it was catching me.
You better be a good shit.
This girl,
she pulls her top up and all these
dudes are groping her and Shit and she's
screaming.
They are wild and Kentucky man does it.
Different briefings can suck.
You don't man.
It's the university that's America
home. Those aren't white. Right?
So that's America.
That's mostly black hands on that white
girls titties and she's a redhead.
Yeah, Brian's was upset. Hits
a little too close to home.
Done dog. Look at this. This
guy's got blood all over him.
He broke his hands open trying to smash
a windshield with his fucking fists.
He's bleeding off of his hands and they
got a close up. But those dickheads face,
well you dummies are going to do time.
You stupid fucks light cars on fire.
You cuts.
How can we can't just
celebrate you shit heads.
You know it's funny is like see
that crowd photo right there? Yeah.
Somewhere in there is a kid that in 20
years is going to be running for Senate.
Ah, and this picture's going
to come up and it's gonna be,
he was there when they write it and
he's also listening to us, right? Yeah.
That little fucker right there.
He looks kind of like the one
he looks like a young Inuit.
A young said Toro. Yeah. What are
you doing? You playing a commercial.
I just want to talk about
the style and performance.
Is that a Hyundai Hyundai's look
like Mercedes Benz? No, it's amazing.
You see that thing that new Hyundai?
Yeah. These stupid fucking kids man.
This shit at noise the fuck out of me.
Cause everybody knew
it was going to happen.
They all knew it guys got it was a crazy
there. Kentucky gentleman in his hand.
That's what he's drinking.
He's like,
do your audiences like psycho and
couldn't be better. Couldn't it?
Couldn't have been better audiences
in on earth. It was impossible. They,
Duncan got a round of applause
and a standing ovation,
not just around applause.
Standing ovation,
every show going on stage going on stage.
He was getting standing ovations. They
couldn't have been nicer, friendlier,
more fun. Louisville was
the shit. It's a fun place.
That's the beautiful thing
about clubs like the Improv,
like look high end clubs is they develop
like people that are like fans of
comedy too.
Like you know there's not a lot of places
in the country where you can guarantee
you're going to see like national level
comedians but you know all the Improv's
you're going to get like all big
name comics going to come through.
They couldn't have been any better man.
That place was amazing.
Louisville's a shit.
Why I got to get to a show.
I haven't been to one in a minute man.
Next time you're in Monday I could
have was about to, I'm about to
uh, lay down a uh, a video I say lay down.
Cause I'm [inaudible] over their job
is when I'm talking to musicians, man,
I like to use their language. They don't
have video laid down a video though, man.
I'm saying that bitch down. You know
some, some uh, comedy on that pitch.
I'm going to put it on Vhs, Joe. Now
Beta, bro. I'm sticking with Beta.
So you wouldn't go there. I mean,
are you already going the route?
The same one as the, this the recently
as Lucy can't guy just threw it out? No,
his idea. I started totally stolen.
I didn't have that idea first. Yeah,
I was trying to gate and have it
first. Either Radiohead today, music.
It was kind of the same
principle, I think. Yeah,
he's the first guy to deal with comedy.
Um,
and now everybody's going to do it that
way. Comedy Central. Yeah, but your folks,
man, I'm gonna tell you something about
your folks, man. Hey, your folks love you.
I love them too. I mean, these twice
catch like it's, you know, it's,
I don't want to say that's why I
don't really know why. So I mean,
that happens a lot of folks. That's going
to be hollering at the website, man.
Yeah. You know what, dude,
I really firmly believe that when
you put positive energy out there,
you attract like minded people.
You're going to get a few cots in the mix.
It's inevitable, especially on the
Internet. Especially like an in text form.
Like when dudes get to tweet shitty
things to be bullish on our message boards
or something like that.
Like yeah.
My thing is like do you really
think that stopped my day?
Did he think that slowed me down in my ra?
Yeah.
It's real simple man.
Don't ever say anything to anybody
that you wouldn't say to their face.
Just don't do it. And if you do say it,
say it as if you had say it to their face.
Otherwise you're a cunt.
It's that pretty much if I say something
I'm going to say it to your face.
Like I got a bunch of negative tweets
here that night cause so some dude in
front of the country music awards.
Okay.
Homeboy is standing there with fake
rips in his jeans like you bought.
Jeans are already pre ripped and he's
standing in front of a jet and I dunno if
the song was any good cause quite honestly
I said the song was, I said, here's,
I go,
this is country I dudes wearing fake
ripped jeans standing in front of a jet
singing shitty song. And then the
Hashtag was that ain't country. No,
but it's silly jeans. You're a
silly bitch. You're a silly bitch.
If you weren't fucking
fake ripped jeans period.
Thousand 12 ever had fake ripped jeans.
Yeah, I might've. I might've. Yeah,
I might have bought some.
Yeah.
Did you ever used to bleach your genes
in the basement where report actual real
bleach on your genes in the 80s no,
I didn't
definitely have owned a pair
of jeans with rips in them.
They might've been like given to
me from wardrobe on fear factor,
but I had them in a warm, but it's, I'm,
I'm old enough now to realize that's
ridiculous. Kind of ridiculous.
Very Nickelback by the way.
Yeah.
But I bet you it's easy to buy him by
mistake nowadays because now they have
genes that just look like
they're fucked up a little.
But then you wash them once
and they become ripped jeans,
you know like where the, the the
clothing is like very thin. Yeah.
Like you can buy it by mistake going
while those genes and the next thing you
know you have some ripped jeans and
you're at the rainbow room. Yeah.
But this dude had brand new five o ones.
If I were a junior, that's my new thing.
Man. I just got them. I love all the way
to do it. Crispy. I don't even wash them.
These have not been washed like
cardboard man. No, I'm serious.
This is how we're going.
Then I throw them away.
That's Bala. That's hilarious.
That's it. A Charlie Murphy. I live,
I live at the sergeant supply sergeant
supply over there in Burbank, man.
It really? Yeah. Was Five
Oh ones all day long, man.
Just get a new pair
every week on the road.
I throw up like 14 pairs of no in
the last like three shows. Really?
Yeah. You could probably sell those
sits up so much on the bus and stuff.
I wear gym shorts and just
kind of lounge around, so,
but do you actually throw them out
and you give them to like goodwill or
something nice. Kind of usually
leave him in a hotel. You should.
I really want it. Usually on solar I
sweat so much, like in those things, man,
every, it'd be like, you know,
I don't have time to wash them and I'm
not trying to give him the goodwill,
like just loaded with my, you're loaded
with my DNA, you know what I mean?
I bet there's some people out
there that would buy it big, big.
I'll just start tweeting hotel rooms
across. Yeah. I'm leaving some jeans here.
Ate Taco bell earlier. Might smell
great. Yeah. Yeah. You should just, yeah.
This is going to be dudes who
it'd be jerking off sniffing.
It's a doozy.
I got really real up.
I'll never throw another way of
five oh one four the stinky
in my pinky. Okay. What?
I think you need to play a
song, just a curious of what
he does. Right. By the way,
that surplus store is really awesome
and I go there to buy like fucking gas
masks and crazy shit all the time.
But then I feel like people actually
wore these and died in Nepal where like
military pants and jeans is what I
wear. So yeah, that's my wardrobe man.
Those are the best. Like
cargo pants fit so much. Shit.
I don't need to carry around my
fanny pack. I've got a fanny pack.
People think I'm bullshitting.
Catch me at the airport.
Ready to sweat my fanny pack.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Here we go.
[inaudible]
hear that shade come around.
Ben Ne seen search since
now stood game. Fulsom prison. Takis,
it happened right there.
You're live witness.
I hit the wrong chord and
I'm not going to live with it
and we want to take that one
more time. Oh from the top? Yeah.
[inaudible]
hear that train coming.
Come in around nine seen such since
I announced the canned food soon.
Chris tack,
he's Jag
and that changes keys
now saying so
when I was just failing,
my mom
always be good bone Napa.
But that's sad man.
[inaudible]
when I hear that whistle
blow hang my head and craft.
Good Lord.
I just hang my head.
[inaudible]
Friday rich fans,
Danny call prior to June,
get whiskey and smell
God.
Well,
I knew I had it come in
new at Camp [inaudible]
and NASA [inaudible] green mint from his
prison that will train proud of jasmine
five down and Lang Bobby Bussan.
We allow to
Dave
and Madeline down on some
lists blew out my blue, so,
oh wait.
[inaudible]
damn. That is so awesome.
That's a beautiful cover man.
God Damn. What a fucking song that is.
Yeah. I remember when I wrote it, man,
it was real hard back in
the day and another 59,
man, I'm so stoned with watching this.
[inaudible] it's almost too much. Really?
Yeah. It's just, uh, it's, it's
like freaks me out a little,
being able to just see this so close
to me. I don't know. It's weird.
This would be the dopest intimate
concert of all time. Yeah.
My dog's named Johnny Cash. Is that
right? Who did Johnny Cash Fan?
I had a rottweiler named Elvis. Uh,
I had a pit bull named Frank Sinatra.
That's awesome. But that was before
I really got to know Frank Sinatra.
Personality still is frank.
Oh Man.
But better off having a pit bull
named frank. I'll raise you with Tony.
Tony Bennett. I had a cat
named skittles. Skittles. Yeah.
I had a uh,
in Florida shoot him
cat named Jack Dempsey. I should a ride.
I just got to say, and I don't care.
I don't care what the kid did. You can
see they're saying, oh, I'm going there.
Was that all right? Okay, good. Can I go
there on this Trayvon Martin thing? My,
my take on it? Yeah. Yeah, please.
No matter what the kid did.
There's two kinds of 17.
There's Lebron James 17.
It looks like a 36 year old man. Right,
right, right. And then there's child 17,
and I haven't seen one picture of this
kid that isn't a child. 17. And this dude,
ways of outweighed him by a hundred
pounds. 100 million. Yeah. Italy. Oh,
it's, you seen the size of the dude
and I pictures from what I'm seeing,
I'm guessing on that one. On the wait.
Okay. Outweighed him significantly.
Regardless of that. Most he's in
danger of his blood or broken jaw.
Maybe a black guy.
His story and I don't know what happened.
I'm just saying grown man against a kid.
I'm talking about me against
a 17 year old kid. I need to,
there's no kid on earth that,
that looks like that in the eyes.
Like a baby, like a child.
Not like a grown man,
like dude who's been like through the,
you know,
the client is going to put me
on my back and kill me. Yeah,
but that's you. This guy
might've been kind of a bitch,
you know. I mean this guy,
I'm just saying murder's murder.
He tried to be a cop and
as far as I'm concerned,
the one that stood his ground at
night is the one that's dead baby.
But maybe not.
You know his stories that the kid came
back and attacked him and he actually has
supposedly ABC news
was reporting Destinee.
They've enhanced the video and they
found cuts in the back of his head.
Which Shannon on the back of your head.
I just don't see it as worth
killing somebody. I agree with you.
But I mean his story is the
kid was trying to get his gun.
His story is told you not to follow.
Dude, police told you stay out of it.
[inaudible] this is a man who thought he
was an authority figure and was itching
to use his gun. That's the bottom
line. And I'll leave her to town.
But he did apparently according
to the nine one one call,
they told him to turn around and he
did turn around and his story is,
that's when the kid jumped up.
I don't know what the fuck is true.
I don't know what he could have said to
the kid to piss them off like that if he
did. You know, I,
I definitely agree that
dude was into being, uh,
itching uses gun man. But it also
could have been that, you know,
they were in a life and death
struggle. I wasn't mad, man.
I agree that the only reason it was us,
we,
if it was a life and death struggle
though, you'll get grant Munis.
And the only reason it was because one
of them brought a gun and it wasn't the
kid. That's true. Yeah. And he, he thought
he now had there not been a gun there.
The worst that could have probably
happened in the situation was one of the
others got their ass kicked. Right.
Right. If there hadn't been against,
there was no gun at the scene.
But his deal is that he's trying to be
like neighborhood patrol man with a gun.
Well it would would be wants to somebody,
actually you have a gun,
you want to shoot somebody need
when there's bad people out there.
That kid was not what he was looking
for obviously. But I'm saying,
but hold on a second.
You know that in that neighborhood,
a man is in critical condition right
now of 50 year old guy who got beaten
almost to death with hammers and two
to 18 year old kids were arrested.
They robbed him and they beat the
fuck out of this guy with hammers.
So it's not like there's not bad people
in the world that you could use a gun.
There was no, I agree. Are there
wouldn't be a dead person. That is true,
but that is this scenario. There
could have been an easily a scenario.
This is a very bad area with these people
who live in and there's a lot of break
and entries as a lot of robbery.
A lot of us. You're right.
Which is why in the correct manner,
I'm just saying studio, they are.
When I look at decade, well I do
as well, but he's just that kid.
That's a terrible situation.
Real mother fucker could sense evil.
You know what I mean?
Like the kind of evil that would
beat up man to death with hammers.
That you could sense that Joe, you can
feel that in the air. I agree. I agree.
But again, if that was his story, I
don't know what the fuck happened Bro.
But his story is that the kid jumped him.
That's his story.
If that's his story yet. Yeah. Well it's
been, it's been out there. It's been,
I ain't heard him tell his with his words.
Yeah, I ain't heard him tell his story.
You know,
I haven't heard anybody else if be sat
here in front of me and told his story
and I looked in his eyes and I
believed him. That's a different,
but do you understand that? I don't
want no one's talked. No one's talked.
We're getting all Nancy Grayson saying,
I see a little baby.
I'm saying I'm not even talking about
race a race. Nothing else aside.
I'm saying had a man that was itching,
itching to be a bad ass with a gun,
not brought a gun to a situation
that didn't need it anyways. True.
There wouldn't be a dead person.
If a guy that's wrongful death,
that's murder man. You had some big
John McCarthy type cop out there.
Nothing would ever happened. He would've
said the kid, how are you doing tonight?
And the kid who said, I'm all good, and
they would have said, have a good night.
Be careful in.
That would've been the end of it.
It's a lot of it is people
that are looking for trouble
and a lot of the reason
why they're looking for troubles that
cause they're insecure and this easily
could have been with this guy was deal is,
I don't know the dude. I'm just saying,
I see your baby days. That bothers me.
That is the Bob is a fuck out of me.
I'll be honest, if those pictures
had looked like he was a hood,
I would probably feel a lot different.
I'd probably be like, Oh man,
looks like he's kind of a hood,
but I don't.
It's just looks like a kind of kid to
me. It's true. It is true. But you know,
I don't bring a gun against a kid man.
I'm just saying,
I thought he was going to run
into kids though. You know,
he's patrolling to run into a situation
where he could pull out his gun.
Maybe you might be right or why else
would you carry it if you're not your
average police officer?
I bet you your average real like
normal personality of a human being,
police officer,
Pri does not like the fact that all
that they have a gun all the time.
I would disagree with that heavily.
I have a lot of friends that use of it
would be not a lot of friends that are
cops. They don't want to pull that
gun out. That's for God. Damn.
That's what I mean. I mean in
a sense that the, you know,
the thought of using it is actually
very foreboding and not something
interesting at all.
I have friends that have shot people
before and you talked to them about and
then it's not a pleasant memory. It's
not a good thing, you know? Uh, I've,
I've, I've had, that's
the thing on your belt,
the last thing you ever really
want to have to reach for.
I had a conversation with the dude just
a couple of weeks after you had a shoot
dude. And he was, you know,
just start starting to get back into the
swing of things in his head. You know,
just dealing with the fact, he's like,
I'm happy I did it. He goes like,
I was a piece of shit.
But let me tell you,
it's to fucking tricky thing taking
a man's life. Yeah, it's crazy.
I would like to hear the
dude tell the story. Yeah.
I would tell me I wish I hadn't is
doing more harm than good while his
[inaudible] you know the real issue
though is there's the legal issue.
I mean this guy, if he is
innocent, if you are innocent,
you really should shut the fuck up
until your lawyers get your, you know,
get everything in the proper order.
And this too many channels right
now for prosecutors to go after,
people that aren't necessarily guilty.
And there's a lot of people behind
bars right now that if they had better
representation,
if they didn't open the fucking mouth.
I'm not saying in this guy's case,
but if the guy is innocent,
he really probably should shut the fuck
up until he actually goes to trial or
talks to the prom. But him going on, Larry
King, sorry. Can't do anything anymore.
No, him going on Pierce Morgan, here's,
you know that ain't got his brother was
on piers Morgan though. Yeah, I didn't.
I missed that. Yeah, his brother
was on. I didn't mean to go there,
but I just know let's man,
you went there because it's a part
of my culture kind of bugs me.
You know what I mean? It's like God needed
to, you know? I just feel like I said,
there's, there's two different
17 year olds and you know,
I don't know if you want, if you, if
you miss doing neighborhood watch, you,
you're supposed to be looking
out for your community.
How do you know that wasn't
a person from your community?
You must not approach them
in a manner that was like,
excuse me sir, or excuse me,
what's going on?
You know what I mean?
There must've been some real rude
shit and if you didn't bring a gun,
nobody would be dead.
That is true,
but that's my biggest point is that if
the dude that wasn't itching to use his
weapon didn't bring a weapon,
there probably wouldn't be
even anything except a kid.
And you know that got scraped up in a
scuffle or a man that got scraped up in a
scat. That is true in
this situation, you know?
But against this guy I'm talking about,
that's not necessarily what this guy
was looking for when he's armed doing is
neighborhood watch. He's looking
for people like these two kids.
One of them's 18 five foot eight and he
was wearing a blue denim shirt and he
beat a fucking 50 year old man with a
hammer. You know, that guy's fucked up.
That guy is severely fucked up and we'll
probably never be the same human being
again. He might die. I wonder if he dies.
They'll pay as much attention
as this kid that got shot.
Cause it's Kinda fascinating man.
You know,
there's a lot of people that are real
squeamish about talking about black kids
doing something violent to wipe you
out. I ain't got no problem. We were,
you raised him. I know. You know
what I mean? I don't need to,
I gotta say I admit it openly.
Like if it looked a lot more hood,
I'd probably would mentally feel
different about it. That's just natural.
What your mind works.
I'm talking about our culture.
I'm not necessarily talking about you.
I think on our culture it's a,
it's interesting. We all have a little
bit of that regardless of all of us on it.
We're also looking to catch people in a
Gotcha moment of racism. We love that.
We would love to find someone who
especially saw a safe situation like that.
And to
be honest, the real problem
isn't even Ms. Dot. Zimmerman.
The real problem is this law called
the stand your ground law that says,
if me and you are in a place
basically and nobody else is around,
and I say you attack me and make
it look that way, you can shoot,
I can easily kill you
and get away with it.
Cool. And it's just two people, man.
It's fucking hard to figure out
what the hell happened. Exactly.
I know there's a lot of crazy fuckers
out there that can just tell lies, man.
You know there's a, there's
a lot of people out there
that are completely socio.
Exactly. So if you give them opportunity
to use their gun in a situation,
it's like a lot of people could start
disappearing or falling victim to a,
you know,
a self defense.
Who would you like actually moved to
Florida just so they could shoot people
easier. You know, just start some
arguments. I went down here, man.
I went down in Florida is one of the
weirdest fucking places in the country.
It really does feel like you're in
another place. I'm there in two weeks.
I'm doing not a Improv in Fort Lauderdale.
I like going down there.
They know how to party.
There are a lot of fun people,
but it really feels like you're on
an island somewhere and you know,
in another country that it's
like subject to us rules.
But no one's really watching. Let's
kind of like to wow. You know,
still the 80s down there in a weird
way. Yeah. In a lot of ways. Yeah.
It's Florida strange kind of
where the whole place is built on
cocaine money,
man.
Literally like literally there's that
whole like you've seen the cocaine cowboys
like, right? Yeah. Like my f downtown.
Miami's like literally
built with kilos of cocaine.
They just poured it into the cement.
Yeah. It's amazing. It's
so ridiculous. What I,
there's more banks per capita
apparently in Miami than anywhere.
It's all just money laundering
going down left and right.
If you haven't seen cocaine cowboys folks,
we've talked about it before, you must,
you must,
can, you must see it. See? Yes, yes, yes.
To that was to the US and then with
the grant. The godmother. Yeah,
the Godmother who's alive. This bitch
is killed. Who knows how many fucking,
and she's just chilling.
So she made like 500 mil a year in jail
and she was such a bad ass bitch that
ain't even tried to kill her
a woman and they just let her run shit.
Oh my God.
That's a crazy documentary.
Yeah.
I think Miami's the closest to a foreign
country we have in America outside of
Puerto Rico, which is technically
sort of America, right?
Isn't cause I still don't
think debating that recently.
Like whether they want to become a
state finally come on, just be a state.
What do you give a fuck? But it's cool
to fucks up all the flags though, man.
We got everybody's got to get a
new flag. Yeah, right on my harbor.
Some resentment.
Where would we put that extra
star? Where the fuck is that
going to go? I don't know. Spit,
you know that's going to take like a
some sort of mathematical seamstress type
to figure out weird shit like Hawaii.
Five hours in a fucking room
lane over the ocean and yet
it's still America, Alaska.
I had some Alaskans come to the last
show and they were telling me like, who
do, how do I tip you? Uh, after
I got off stage and I'm like,
what are you talking about? Goes, I'm
well, I want to tip you. And I'm like, no,
you don't take, he's like, oh,
this is my first comedy show and it's the
most insane thing I've ever seen in my
life and it's, I want to
tip you. I'm like, no,
don't tip me what the
fuck you're talking about.
But it was so weird talking that he seemed
like he was from a different country.
Like he, he, he was talking all
this other things like that.
Well, essentially they are. Yeah. I mean
it really is. It's not attached. Right.
I mean, my joke, if it's not attached,
it's just some shit we stole. Right.
That is what it is. Or Barn. Yeah.
Would you ever go to the Indian bought
from somebody who stole it fucking
whiskey and they took
Manhattan for like seven bucks.
Would you ever go to Alaska to do comedy
or do you think is like now you people
there for that? Yeah,
it was pretty Douglas.
Stan hope used to go there all the time,
but they just got to be too stupid
for him. He bailed after awhile.
He couldn't take it anymore.
Did get pretty nutty up
there. From what I hear, man.
Hell yeah. They do six months a day
live six months and night. Yeah.
And there's bears everywhere and you know,
it's fucking crazy.
You live in nutty place.
It's ridiculous.
He live in a place where humans,
humans aren't necessarily supposed to be.
It's for fucking for reason. For a good
chunk of the year. Like death freezing,
like Antarctic style freezing this,
this, I couldn't do it. Yeah, that's,
that's hard. Do you ever see
that movie 30 days of night?
Is it a vampire movie? Yeah, pretty good
vampire movie man. And they, uh, the,
the vampires go to Alaska because they
could just fuck people up for a whole
month.
It doesn't get light out for a month.
That's gotta be depressing a shit,
you know? I mean you think say
adol is depressing Seattle.
How am I went to Copenhagen and uh,
we land in and we went to this place,
we had heard of this legendary
place called Christianity.
I don't know if you're familiar.
It's like a place that squatters took
over apparently in, and they were legally,
they, it's basically a little section
in the middle of the city where they,
they can slang hash
and weed and they just,
government kind of looks the other way.
They're squatters.
But every once in a while the government
goes in there and like tries to rate it
and they fight him off. It's crazy. This
little section is called Christiania.
How big is it? It's tiny. The Cup.
It's like maybe six blocks of land.
So it was just within
like a gate and it's like,
it looks like a hippie community.
Like looks like little
little gardens in this nap.
And then you walk down this road and
they got all these sheds set up and their
slang in weed there. Wow. Good weed. Yeah.
So like I remember we
got some real good way.
Went back to the hotel and smoked up and
it was about seven in the evening and
the sun was still out. So Bang, let me
smoke weed. This weed knocked me out.
I fell out. I wake up, I look at my
watch and says, three, I look outside,
it's light. It's, I was like, man,
that shit knock me out from seven last
night, two to three the next afternoon,
Jesus Christ. So I go downstairs
and I'm talking to the lady,
something about something at the desk
and I'm like, yeah, I was there. Where's,
where's a good place to eat?
She's like, sir, it's three
in the morning. She's like,
it's not three in the,
that blew my mind. It's short circuited
me. That was one day, right? Like it,
it screwed me on where I went up to the
room and like my brain was having a hard
time processing the thought of the sun
being out bright as hell at three in the
morning. How long is it bright for? If
he goes down apparently for like an hour,
like between 12 and one every night it
kind of goes down and it doesn't ever go
all the way down. It's kind of
dusk and then it comes back up.
It's must be so happy that
certain times of the year,
this is like summertime and um, I bet the
winters, I don't know if it's different,
I don't know if they suffered
the opposite, but it was like,
it's short circuiting me.
So what my point is is like six months
of something like that. Yeah. Would,
would pry fry your board man,
I'm pretty sure they do in Alaska.
I'm pretty sure in Alaska there's moments
where they have like almost perpetual
sunlight.
I think they just have like an hour
where it goes down for a little bit and
comes back up.
I think that's the case up there too.
His Copenhagen's pretty far up there,
man.
It's weird that they would just decide
to like not have things open at three in
the morning when it's bright out. Just
stay the dead. Come on. It's like,
why are you doing hire somebody
or if you had a data business,
do you know that could be
your option to do? Yeah.
The reason why shit is closed is because
he can't see outside without lights on.
That's why shit's closed.
Okay.
Now that he could see how the side
with lights on keep shit open. Yeah.
Why fuck you doing man? What do you need
to sleep or something? What do you hate?
Money. I hate money and he'd asleep.
What is your favorite place to tour?
Do you have a favorite country to go to?
Um,
I'm really a big vantage of pan just
because it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's the place where I feel the most
foreign. You know what I mean? It's like,
I honestly feel like a foreigner and
I enjoy that feeling like of being the
different one. Kind of. Yeah. You know,
even though it's got your two guys in,
you know more than I, but I've never
run into anything. Well there's,
there's one Sushi bar they wouldn't
serve me because I was guiding the, yeah.
Then I went to this bar and then died.
Apparently the dude just wasn't that did
on serve guys. Gene at this bar. Wow.
Forget the name of it. But how long
ago was this? This recent? No, no,
within a decade,
but like eight,
nine years ago and probably Brian and
I just want a couple of weeks ago.
First Time you actually longer,
maybe like 15 years ago. Damn. Yeah.
I wonder if it's changed now.
Maybe we haven't heard that associated
with old cats that are just like,
I'm not giving you my fish.
Yeah.
I re I remembered 60 years ago
and you can't have my fish.
Yeah. How old was it, dude? Do you think
he was alive back then? I don't know.
But you know old the
old enough. Yeah. Yeah,
but don't fucking crazy thing
for a country to go through.
Could you imagine if we found out like
Chicago disappeared in the middle of the
night, you know, Chicago and
Phoenix disappeared. Boom.
In like in a second gone.
How would we react to some country
that just took Chicago and Phoenix just
vaporized? It just vaporized
500,000 people, whatever.
Fuck it was. We're the only ones I've
ever did it. Woo. That's dark. It's crazy.
It's dark.
It's really crazy.
If you ever look at all the different
weapons that are wive like that,
the United States has all the different
nuclear warheads you seen like a map of
like Russia's nuclear warheads,
United States
doing car warheads. I ran,
supposedly is working on some shit,
but Israel's got a ton of shit.
Pakistan has nuclear weapons and nuclear
weapons, you know, they're like, hey,
I ran, can't have them. But
everybody's got 'em, you know? Yeah.
They shouldn't have them, but nobody
should have, um, North Korea's gone. Um,
it's really amazing when you look
at how many of them there are.
Like if you look at a
map of the United or the,
the entire world rather than all the,
the nuclear arsenal,
we could wipe out the whole planet
completely. Oh, many, many times over.
That's insane. And I don't know
how they're ever going to fix that.
How are they going to stop those
things, you know, from being active.
Gotcha.
Do trigger that.
The law of averages says sometime whether
it's now or a thousand years from now,
some of that Shit's gonna
pop off. Yeah. People believe
that that happened in the past.
There's a lot of people that believed
that there was, at one point in time,
people had figured out a nuclear
power and we had a, there's,
there's like evidence of giant, massive
explosions and parts of like, uh,
the Middle East and stuff like that.
I,
it'd be able to believe it was Lebanon
or something like that where people
believe this.
It's one of those old ancient
civilization Atlantis ideas. Yeah.
We'll bring some along those lines.
You know,
that they think that at one point in
time we had figured out nuclear power.
They know, he figured out
batteries. They had batteries.
They found in like the pyramids and Shit,
which is pretty fascinating. You know,
they figured out some shit,
but I doubt they ever had nuclear power.
That's pretty preposterous. The aliens,
man, d aliens do. Aliens did it too.
If the aliens come,
was that a good thing or bad thing?
The aliens aren't already here.
Then we,
then we talk about my alien technology
or any your alien, alien technology,
you know your heart.
Yeah. It's titanium valve.
I firmly believe there's Dalian technology
here, dog be, it's absolutely married.
How do you think that works?
They just give us a little
stuff and tell us to evolve,
you know, or you know, if you know, okay.
Let you know or similar to something of,
you know, some things that got left
behind and just got studied in front,
properly looked at.
You know what I mean?
Like some terminator where they got the
little chip and they're like backwards
engineering every Jane, you
know what I mean? You know?
Or it's something that we already
have that we just take for granted.
Like birds or something.
Like birds are the aliens the whole time.
Why did the array of conversation,
I forgot how wide the span of
topics get on it. Yeah. Well I think
that's, it's just like having a real
conversation, right? Oh yeah. You know,
amongst owners. Yeah. Fuck
yeah. I think, um, if, uh,
if aliens are here and I don't
think they're giving us anything,
I don't believe that I did.
I don't know if we've ever captured
any alien craft and back engineered it.
It sounds sexy, but it also sounds like
a crock of shit. I know. I don't buy it.
There's not a big enough leap. You
know, there's some leaps, you know,
like the transistor, there's a few
things in the fuel look back at like,
but it's all pretty much documented how
everybody figured out everything and
every step along the way.
I used to think before I looked into it
that maybe there was some shit that the,
the army learn from Roswell and you know,
that may be the, they'd figured, Eh,
now I don't think so. He just shit on our
cars. Yeah. Well, you know what? I think,
man, I think, uh, if we have had
some contact with an alien life form,
I think there's so fucking far past us
that they can pause the earth and sweep
up and then disappear again.
I mean,
I think we're dealing with some
mother fuckers food. Yeah. Or, yeah,
we could be that. Well, I wish
they would eat some more of us.
There's too many of us, you
know, too many shitheads.
There should be a test and if you know,
if you don't pass the test,
you get fucking turned into barbecue.
Like, like Logan's runners. Yeah.
But then you don't want people to miss
their family and their loved ones.
I don't want you to lose your,
your family cause you're a dumb ass
and the alien came and eight you,
I would have to be fighting with you
against the aliens was that would probably
turn most douche bags into, you know,
probably more respectable people anyway.
That's true. Right? Yeah.
If we knew that there was a alien that
was watching there was going to eat you
if you were a client. Yeah. That would
be good incentive to not be a continent.
But then it'd be suicide by alien.
People just caught off.
Just fucking run around breaking windows,
lose it for a day.
Suicide by alien man.
Girl breaks up you I'm going fucking to
by alien and people see him running down
the street.
Fuck you.
Fuck you throwing rocks and shit and
everybody watches because they know what's
going to happen. Aliens show up, eat them.
Hey could happen. What was it? What was
the song will make great pets. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, we will. Well, you know,
if you look at how we treat
everything that's intelligent,
that we don't understand,
like dolphins and orchestras and,
and even primates like chimpanzee
would treat them like shit.
It put them in cages and shit.
You know, we, we don't know.
We don't necessarily enhanced her life.
Went out there given chimpanzees laptops
and showing him how to spell in a,
we teach them a few things
to get do tricks for candy
so we could figure out how
smart they are. But that's no different
than studying prisoners. You know,
that's like psychological tests on
prisoners. That's all that shit is.
It's really funny that we would think that
aliens would be any different than us.
If you look at every single intelligent
species on this planet, you know,
even semi-intelligent, they all take
advantage of those underneath them.
Killer whales eat dolphins, dolphins
eat their babies. Chimps eat monkeys.
We were cunts,
all lifeforms on this planet.
It seems like her cunt. So we're,
we're, we're hoping that if there are,
and you know,
it is
not an alien life form that's super
intelligent. We're hoping they're not,
they're better than us. They're
way better than us. We're,
we're trusting that they've
got their shit together. Oh,
I'm not trusting anything.
I'm just saying that we might have
learned a few things in the last few years
off or some shit. Yeah. I wouldn't trust
the alien far as I could throw him.
But you really think we've learned
things from a back engineered alien
technology. I like to
believe it. I believe it to
believe it. I can't prove it.
I love to believe can prove it.
I wouldn't swear to it.
If you told me like my life depended
on it, would you swear to it? I'd say,
Oh fuck. Now it probably is
bullshit. I have on my wall.
I have a framed the daily Roswell
daily record or whatever the fuck the
newspaper is that the very newspaper where
they reported that they had a crashed
Ufo,
that they've recovered it,
that they've sent the parts of it
to Wright Patterson Air Force Base.
They thought they had something man.
I mean they put the shit in the
paper that it was a crashed UFO.
Wonder what it was. You
know, I really wish I had,
I talked to g Gordon Liddy about
this shit. I had g Gordon Liddy.
I mean there is an area 51 out there. You
go knowing that Neil come and kill you,
they'll kill you. Yeah. They
shoot on sight when I am,
I ain't romanticizing them and I
just, I just know, look at stars,
there's a billion of them to think
during some other life forms out there is
just, you know, a little bit
arrogant. Yeah, for sure.
I just don't know if they come here,
maybe not. Might be really hard to do.
It might be too hard even for like if
you want to get real stoner and you know,
we can be like,
well,
maybe if they were that advanced they
wouldn't even need these ships and all
this crap. They'd traveled in
interdimensionally. Well, you know,
the real theory that
that trips me out, man,
is that we came from Mars.
The real theory is that the reason why
human life is different from all the
other primate life on this planet is
that what had happened was there had been
the development of lower hominids on this,
on this planet that were like reaching
close towards being like a human being,
but hadn't quite gotten there.
Right.
But we were existing on a
completely different planet.
Mars and Mars used to have water.
Mars used to have an atmosphere of faces.
I don't believe in all that. I think that
most of it looks like bullshit. Yeah.
Most of it looks like tricks and shadows.
If you really pay attention to the high
resolution photos and the experts that
have and that people
want to see some shit,
but most likely it's
just tricks and shadows.
There's a few objects up there like the
pyramid looking things that make you go,
Huh, but there's some natural
things that look like this.
Things called the yardangs, you
know, that look like they're,
they're like a look like
a face carved on a rock.
But it really is just the
natural stone structure.
Did you read the book about all that?
Yeah.
Graham Hancock's book or read
his book about it, right.
Cause against women are from Venus,
men are from Mars or whatever.
Not that book is, um, it's uh,
there's a lot of dudes who believed
that there was at one point in time a
civilization on Mars that made
its way to earth many, many, many,
many thousands of years ago. And it was
like started humping the finer lake.
Primate chicks think we're them. I think
the idea is that we're them. You know,
the, the, I think the doe guns in, uh,
Africa, a whole tribe and that's their,
their entire mythology there at Tyler
entire mythology is based on the fact that
we are a tribe from Mars
and that we came here
fucking fascinating show. Have to Google
that one. I'm going to have to Google.
That one is fascinating shit,
man.
I don't think it's possible, but yet look
bad. We put a fucking rover on Mars, man.
We flew a fuck on rover and we're
taking pictures from Mars all day. Yeah,
I mean they have all kinds
of cool shit going on.
High resolution closeup photos and we
know that we can put a man in space and we
know we can fucking send an object to,
to Mars and if we can get someone
in space to stay alive and you know,
not the cook them with gamma ray bursts
from giant Starks exploding out there in
the galaxy, which is very
possible, you know? But if,
if we can get them all the way to Mars,
like six months and they stay alive,
they've got enough food, dude, they
can do what's called terraforming,
where they can build machines that
are big enough to actually create an
artificial atmosphere on Mars.
That's like, that's possible.
Even within our lifetime,
if they really started
dedicating themselves towards
it. That's some crazy shit,
man. Maybe spending some of these billions
there. Yeah. Fuck all this watershed.
Could you imagine if they really did
establish a base on the moon and a base on
Mars? Could you fucking imagine
how crazy that would feel?
Just to know as we are now, that
would have happened. Like as kids,
we were told 2012 oh my God,
it's going to be Jetsons land out there.
Well, that's the big argument against
the moon landing. You know, there's,
there's not a whole lot of
arguments against the moon
landing. That makes sense.
And this is coming from someone
as argued it, I've said to people,
I don't believe we landed on
the moon. That's ridiculous. I,
what the fuck do I know? I have
no idea. It's preposterous.
But I do know that there hasn't
been anything from 1969 cheaper,
easier a fastener behind you on
that. But, but the moon landings,
it's a fascinating subject. You know, I,
I think most likely what happened
is they did put people on the moon,
but they faked a lot of the footage.
There's some of that footage,
some photographs that look fake as fuck.
There's even a guy named Jay Wiener
who made a documentary about it.
There's something called a,
a front screen projection method of
filming things before they had a green
screen and I'm co Kubrick used it in
2001 and his idea is that that's the same
techniques they use to fake
some of these uh, videos.
And he doesn't believe that that
the moon landing was a hoax.
But what he believes is that some of
the video is, it's actually faked.
Yeah. Preposterous. Yes. And
uh, it's really, uh, it's a,
it's a fascinating subject,
especially when you consider the fact
that we know that they definitely fake
some propaganda photos from earlier.
NASA had these pictures of Michael
Collins and he was a attached like by wire
says thing like doing training exercises.
And all they did was take that and they
cropped him and put it in the like a
black background and they
said he was on a moonwalk.
It's the exact photo.
So we know that that
was a standard practice.
We know that there was at least
some shenanigans going on for sure.
Or someone decided to take
a photo and black it out.
So his idea was that it's much more
likely that they went. But you know,
first of all, your fucking, if they did
go, there's a lot of radiation and shit.
You're dealing with you.
You're telling me your,
your film's going to be Hunky dory out
there at 250 degrees on the moon with all
the fucking radiation. You can't
even put your, your film through the,
the airport metal detector.
It gets fucked up,
especially back in 1969 and these were
like regular special Hasselblad cameras
that were designed for the moon landing,
but there were no different
than the camera's on earth.
They weren't like super
insulated or something like that.
The whole thing is fascinating to me, man.
I could, I could trip on it for hours.
I wish I knew a dude who is really, really
smart who didn't believe it, you know?
But I don't everybody that I know that
doesn't believe it is only marginally
smart and they're really smart dudes
that I know believe we went to the moon.
So it's a fucking, it's a
real tough argument, right?
You know everything you think
we went or no, I don't know.
See this one of them things.
Yeah.
I was convinced days. There's days when
I'm like, my biggest thing is like you,
it's like, why haven't we been
back? Why haven't you been back
once in 60? [inaudible] 70 [inaudible]
almost 50 years. Yeah. Apparently there's,
they were making fun of me about this on
some podcast called the skeptic's guide
to the universe. I, I haven't heard
it. I heard it's funny though,
and I would make fun of me too,
especially if I was a scientist
and I actually knew things,
you know? But there's,
there's certain things that I find
absolutely fascinating about conspiracy
theory and the moon
landing is my favorite one.
That's my number one one.
Yes. That's a good one too.
That's a good one. And AIDS is
not real. That's my other one.
That's a good one too.
I never heard that. Oh,
that's a fascinating one.
That's, uh, that's one. Um,
bye. [inaudible]. This is
a guy named Peter Duesberg,
who's a biologist to do to prove yourself,
like supposedly pricked himself with
the, with who? I don't know about that.
I remember it. I thought, I remember
back in the day like some doctor,
actually I'd say you had something that
was supposedly aids virus and freaked
himself with it. Yeah, no, I
don't know if that's the same guy.
This was a while back though.
I'm going to read you a quote from Bill
Clinton and we can get off the spoon
thing,
and this is one of my favorite all time
quotes at anybody's ever said in regards
to a conspiracy theory is,
is uh, Bill Clinton. Uh,
in his book he wrote just a month before
Apollo 11 astronauts buzz Aldrin and
Neil Armstrong had left their colleague
Michael Collins aboard spaceship
Columbia and had walked on the
moon beating by five months.
President Kennedy's goal of putting a man
on the moon before the decade was out.
The old carpenter asked me if I
believed it happened. I said, sure.
I saw it on television and he disagreed.
He said that he didn't believe it.
For a minute and that them television
fellers could make things look real weird,
real, that weren't, he goes back then,
I thought the guy was a crank
during my eight years in Washington.
I saw some things on TV that made me
wonder if he wasn't ahead of his time.
The fucking president said that,
don't fucking president said that. And
all they did was leave a real vague open.
Yeah. Being there. You
shouldn't say that Mr. Clinton.
That is not fair at him. He's having
a laugh about that right there.
Sick in the pits on everybody, man.
He's a troll. Maybe he did that shit.
Sell records or to sell books.
You know.
Could you hear about that dude that said
that a Jimi Hendrix manager killed him?
Have you heard about
that? Yeah, that storm.
I think that's also another buy my
book. You think so? I thought so too,
until I looked into it and uh,
the way he died, he drownded wine,
they said he had nine sleeping pills
in his, in his mouth and uh, you know,
he had swallowed them. And you know,
when he coughed up a lot of it,
nine sleeping pills and literally drowned
in wine, like that's what killed them.
Like it's almost like he was taking
in wine while he was unconscious.
It's really kind of fucked up if
the manager really did kill the guy.
It's absolutely fascinating.
What do,
what does that video of Bill Clinton
dancing? Oh No, it's not. Is it really?
How dare you? Um, this, um,
but this guy who was the singer from
the animals not to do Eric burden.
Now is that as Eric Burdon
the guy who wrote that? Um,
it's Eric Burdon in the animals. The
original animals is always the same guy.
Pretty sure that's not the guy's name.
Maybe it is something [inaudible] hold on.
Uh, no tour manager. That's
what you're going go roadie.
No Rogan and Google me.
You're talking about Kendrick
smart. Oh, there you go.
That's
right.
How in new woo,
what do they come?
Oh
No, no. That's all. I just know that Bart
James, right? That's the dude's name.
Really. James Tapi. Right.
Maybe he wasn't the singer.
Maybe he was one of the dudes in
the band. Okay, I might be wrong,
but the video they showed of him, it
looked like he was the singer. Um,
it's pretty fucking fascinating shit man.
But a lot of people who are
calling bullshit, a lot of
people calling bullshit.
But then other people
believe that it happened.
And one of the reasons they also believe
that happened as because his manager
was a notorious criminal.
Um,
apparently Hendrix had
a really scary manager.
This dude named Michael Jeffrey and he
even had Hendricks kidnap once to show
Hendricks how much power he had.
He had these last kidnap him
and hold him for three days.
I wasn't familiar with all this.
He saved Hendricks.
He came in and saved them and they
said like, see, you know, without me,
you're fucked. And Hendrick's
girlfriend apparently hated him. Well,
Hendricks girlfriend was thrown
off the roof of the Chelsea hotel.
She died and Hendrix died this way.
They're both dead.
And there was a big life insurance policy
apparently on Hendrix. And that's the,
the knock that this guy saying,
he says,
and this Guy James Wright
wrote a book about it. Yeah.
It could be just trying to
sell some books. Could be,
but who the fuck knows who the
manager, Dude's still around. No.
Died in a plane crash, died in a
plane crash on a couple of years.
It makes you wonder though,
if it would've came out of Vinci,
like he might've stuff told somebody
or wrote it down and as [inaudible]
well journal book, apparently the manager
was a scumbag and was always broken,
always owed money and was borrowing
money from the mob. And uh, that was uh,
part of the problem was that the mob was
involved in all this and he was scared
to come out and talk about it.
Who the fuck knows if it's not true,
fuck you in your ass with a broken bottle.
You piece of shit. If you made that up,
you fuck hat of. That's true.
But you know, you'd have to,
you'd have to be a really fucked up
dude to make up a story like that.
Or You could be in a bad situation.
Just needs some cash.
That's the best way to sell a book or
really had a dislike for the person you're
telling the story around,
even though it's dead.
He's been dead since like 1970
something. I think, man, I don't know.
Wish I knew and wishes
nearly.
Dude,
I fancy myself a pretty big Jimi Hendrix
fan and I'm totally unfamiliar with any
of this stuff. Be to girlfriend getting
killed and him die. You know what I mean?
I was, you know, we heard the
legend of him dying on his own,
choking on his own vomit and
yeah, yeah, yeah. I, uh, it,
this all started because a,
I have a thread on my message board where,
um,
it's called the things they got wrong
on the podcast because, you know,
we're always high talking shit. We're,
we're often incorrect, you know,
so I like to look at it
every now and then, you know,
to find maybe some shit I didn't know.
But sometimes people write things
and they don't even bother Google on.
They just say, you're wrong about this.
And like, dude, even research it at all.
Like he said, we were talking
about Hendricks and I'm a
huge Hendrix fan and, uh,
we were talking about
heroin once on the show.
And why is it so many great musicians
love heroin and all these people like
Hendricks. Do you do here? When
he was arrested for heroin,
it was arrested for heroin. He wasn't
a junkie would start it. But I mean,
the crazy thing is like,
why would you even say that?
All you gotta do is just Google it.
Just Google it first. You short,
you know Jimmy so well in it.
But that is, that's leftover.
That's the intranet. The intranet
is going to fix that eventually.
But this is like some leftover
legacy shit where people can write.
It should be like, you
know, there's spell check,
there should be like [inaudible] you
write something on a message board and
Wikipedia, he goes, go fuck
yourself. Stupid. That's not
true. And it just shows you,
it underlines. This is an incorrect
statement. You know, it's uh,
the Internet is going to cure it.
Just like those fuck heads and Kentucky,
the stupid kids or their photos or
blasted across the Internet today the
Internet is going to carry all,
you can't eat.
They used to do that. So over time in Ohio
though like Ohio state, big Ohio State,
Michigan Games and shit like that.
They would, yeah they would have,
you would walk down the street
and cars would just be on fire.
There would be like people would be a
close dumpsters on fire and then they
would bomb the whole entire
neighborhood with a gas.
And so even in your house you're sitting
there fucking eyes watering and shit
and you just had to like wrap towels
around your head. It was certain places,
there's a lot of people with some pent
up energy and they need to blow that shit
out and these dumb fucks had been
doing it for like this for so long.
But now everybody
with their cell phone cameras and shit.
Yeah,
you can't just do, I'd say
did it, it's over. It's over.
Getting away with Shin is just over.
I mean like I don't,
I can't even see like don't,
don't get married if you plan on like
me and like a cheat Eagle worse and
eventually someone's
going to put you on blast.
Somebody going to take care of your
business for you. Yeah. There's no B.
There's no,
you gotta be integrated today.
You've got to be integrated with the hive.
You know,
you know
when wifey can just Google it up.
Or if Twitter's your who's talking to him,
Twitter and Facebook and look in whatever,
there's no privacy,
no more as best business when you
bought it. I volunteer my information,
I'm here and I'm doing
this and here's pictures.
Right.
What do you,
what do you think about people that
are having to give up their Facebook
information to get jobs?
Have you heard that?
I've heard about it again to
give up their Facebook password
before and even started becoming a
story I used to tell like my nephews and
nieces, like I'd see somebody ignorant
shit they'd post and I'd be like, Yo,
this shit never goes
away. Yeah. I was like,
there's going to be a time in a day when
a motherfucker's going to look to hire
you and all of these going to have to
do is Google this and bang all that's
going to be right in a,
in a pre organized section for him.
I tried to get rid of my, my
space. I try to go with, sorry,
they're holding on for dear life. You
can't even delete them. I'm serious, man.
They were supposed to send me email
instructions. I gave him my email address,
send me emails, trucks, and had to leave.
Oh, I must. Oh, it got lost in the email.
You know what they're like, they're
like your girlfriend from high school.
It's like holding out. She really believes
that this whole wife and kids thing,
that shit ain't gonna work out. She's
mad. She just got to hang in there.
Facebook things not gonna last.
Facebook is nothing. Come on.
My space was huge two years ago
before that not been come out.
My experience coming back, they really
want to believe I logged in the other day.
Did you?
I did too.
I had a it and God knows how
long I had that spat about.
Uh,
the country music thing.
I think my, my manager's still
deal with it though. Like,
cause there's parts of the world
where I believe it's still viable.
I don't think so.
Like,
like Russia I think still messes with
my space just to give people viruses.
It's just a good distribution
method for computer viruses.
I went there the other day to prove
that my dog's name was Johnny Cash.
I had to fight.
I knew there was a photo of him somewhere,
something about Johnny Cash.
So I had to find it.
And then the only place was on
my mind space. Yeah. I forgot.
I had a fake band on my space and I
found like, like seven songs I wrote.
One was called Jujitsu and it was all
about Jujitsu and all this other bed.
It's called Java lamps. It's
still on there. Remember my space,
remember what we were going to do with my
space for 10 foot screws? Yeah. Did we,
what we,
one time we were in Denver and
it was me and my boy Eddie Bravo.
And my buddy Tate and Duncan and, and
Brian, and we walked by a wig shop.
We just baked fucking around and
wander through Denver. Great numbers,
a great town. And we see
this wig shop. So we said,
let's just go ahead and see what's up.
For whatever reason we decided
to buy these big crazy wigs.
So all of them wore these wigs and we
pretended to be a band and the band was
called 10 foot screws and this is like
after my comedy show we w w Eddie Bravo
went on stage.
We,
we introduced him as the lead singer
from 10 foot screws and he had the audit,
how, you know, let me
hear some noise over here.
Well like he would go like back and forth
with them and he gave out these flyers
saying that they were free tickets to
the after party and made up an address
like 16th street and El
Pollo Loco just made up.
It was like you had to think something
was going on while it's happening because
everybody was like, there,
there's, this is a stem.
And they wore them for the
whole weekend. Man. It was just,
it was a really ridiculous weekend.
But there's a very funny video about it.
Is that video out there?
How do you find that Brian Shosha
seven 10 foot skirts. Google,
10 foot screws. I mean they were,
it was re some really funny shit.
They had people auditioning
to be in the band.
I remember that dude that got
them to get on his knees. It was,
I'm not doing it justice. You have
to see it. You have to see the video.
I'm going to check it out. Probably
won't be so funny to you feel. It's like,
you know,
if you have a bunch of friends went out
and pretend to be standup comedians and
trans like a stand out. We've got, yeah,
we've done some on the ship and I get it.
Life on the road, man.
Yeah, it gets weird. Right?
Do you go like for long periods
you do just weekends and come?
No, no, that's, I still go out for
a month or two. You know, like,
you know at the time, you
know, if I got to, you know,
if I can do the weekend thing, it's,
it's why the acoustic thing is,
has been becoming kind of convenient.
People are digging on it and
it's easy to do. You know,
I can travel quicker and move faster.
Yeah. When you see a month at a time,
is there, is there, is there leg,
is it logistically more effective
to do a month at a time?
Like once you have the stuff out there,
your equipment, you just keep moving it.
Is that the idea or you just kind of
move from one town to the next and is it
because it's too difficult to fly all
the way revolves more around weekends?
You know what I mean?
Like music Linebough play Wednesday night,
you know what I mean? Awfully Tuesday
night. Right. In a town if you know it's,
yeah,
most comedy does revolve around weekends,
but there's a lot of dudes
who do like off night gigs.
I do a lot of off night gigs for the UFC
cause sometimes we'll do like a fight
night and somewhere Omaha, Nebraska or
some shit on a Wednesday night. So I'll,
you know, I'll have a comedy show
on a Tuesday night. But um, yeah,
music is more of an everyday thing you
think? I guess I've just, you know,
it just seems like, you know, it's,
that's the traveling band man.
You gotta keep it moving.
I mean they're keep loading in lion like
a whole ton of gear just gets old man
gets old. You put it in a
trailer, you're going to,
I mean you gotta still
gotta unload and unpacking.
So you just drag it around what?
You fly it out there once and then you
drag it around and bring a lot of times I
just rolled the bus up here to la
and take off from here. You know?
And so now when you do acoustic, all
you have to do is fly, right? Yeah.
I can fly more, more. I can definitely
get around easier. Are you allowed
to bring a guitar on the
plane? Oh Man. If not,
these cases are built for underneath.
Really? Yeah. They can take a beating.
Let me take a meeting. Did you
see that? Uh, ever see that video?
United Airlines breaks guitars, uh,
after check that one out. I've seen it.
Brian, pull that shit up on
youtube. It's kind of fall.
You're going to freak me out.
Now fanned that make made a song about
it because they were fucking throwing
shit around thinking I don't know about
this. Yeah. It's actually not a bad song.
It's not my kind of
music. But when you, uh,
when you think of the context of how this
guy had to create it and then create a
music video,
air lines on my way to Nebraska,
plane departed.
Hello fax connecting in Chicago.
[inaudible] on the ground
and passengers said,
from seeing behind me [inaudible] my God.
[inaudible]
the abandoned.
I exchanged a look best described as
chair at the action on the tarmac and
knowing who's projectiles these wounds.
The,
so before I left Chicago,
I alerted three employees who show
complete and difference to boards.
[inaudible]
a,
you broke my Taylor Guitar.
[inaudible]
you are, you broke. You should fix it.
I should've flown with
someone else or gone by car.
[inaudible] United breaks guitars.
How many hits video have
11 million.
Suck it United. I think they did.
I think if I remember correctly,
they ended up paying buying new guitars.
Uh Yeah. I think he wouldn't
take it though. I think he
wouldn't take the money.
I think they offered it to him,
but he said no.
He was upset that it took so much and
so long for them to pay that they should
have just paid him like a
normal person should get paid.
What you think of stipulation might've
been take the video down to yeah,
I bet it was. I bet. I bet
that's exactly what it was.
Of course I wouldn't have
gone for that one. Yeah.
One Guitar Bass. You know how
much publicity? 11 million
youtube hits gets slowly.
Shit, I keep getting gigs
off of that. Well, yes.
I never heard of the guy and it's a good,
I mean it's like I said,
it's not necessarily my kind of music,
but it's a good version of it.
That kind of music. It's, he's a good
artist. And then I checked out his
stuff online. He's likes to sort of like
a folksy story. Carol special.com. Yeah,
he's like a folksy type of a
character. That's funny. If you ever,
you never had your shit get
broken? No, I've, I've had clothes.
I used to run with different cases in
this actual guitar that the case like had
a hole punched through it and like,
luckily it didn't do any damage
to that guitar. Ugh. Damn.
That must've freak you the fuck out.
I was,
that's what initiated my second by,
I've had this probably about 10 12 years.
Mother of Pearl in lays in there.
And this is a John Paul Leora Va.
He's like Canadian company.
They make handmade guitars and that
dentists love this guitar. So when is it,
how many differently this? I play
Gibson, like doves and hummingbirds too.
Is it special woods? Like how many
different woods are used in a guitar?
I don't know dude. It's like, you know,
several, but I wouldn't even know.
They're like cars. I don't
know how the hell they work.
I just play him, drive him.
I just play him. I'm, I'm,
one of the things that facet
mates fascinates me the
most about acoustic guitars
is that it's organic.
Like if you're looking at that thing
that's just some lacquer or some clear
finish over some beautiful natural
wood, you know, I love that.
I love that that was created
by a craftsman. You know,
that's not something you could
really do with just a, you know,
a machine in a hole, punch
and spit it out. No, that's a,
that's a real piece of craftsmanship,
you know?
And then I'll just write up here if
you're going to get someone to camera. Oh,
Angel right there. A love that
all mother of Pearl. Right?
Is that abalone or mother
of Pearl? Motherhood. Pearl.
Wow. That's fucking dope.
Yeah, I love it. Yeah, that's,
yeah, that's not just a
musical instrument. I mean,
that's ghetto art. That's a piece of
art or in a lot of my songs on it.
I bet your house. Let's hear another
one. What do you got? Um, yeah.
Well before I do this next one,
I just want to say one of the reasons I
asked you to come on this week was, um,
uh, I've made it pretty public now
that my daughters was born with a,
a disorder called cystic
fibrosis. And, um,
I'm starting to get kind of heavy on
the wanting to get involved in the
fundraising tip,
but,
and I'm actually getting involved with
an organization called the CFF foundation
or the CF foundation,
cff.org if you need any facts
about what CF is, but it's like,
basically I'm a pulmonary and respiratory
disorder and we're basically the cells
kind of processed salt wrong.
And I'm no genius with this.
My wife could explain it to you
perfectly, but basically it, uh,
you develop a whip,
much thicker mucus in your lungs
than normal and they have to, like,
my daughter takes treatments to shake
them loose and whatnot. And essentially,
you know,
that develops over time and kind of
constricts the breathing and leads to,
you know, um, an early demise for
a lot of kids and whatnot. And,
uh, but they're doing a lot of really
good breakthrough work right now.
Like seriously that I could within
the next decade a wrap around this
thing.
It's all privately funded.
I'm going to be doing concerts and
some other things in the future.
But right now we have a team.
I tweeted you about it and
you retweeted it and the link,
I'm sure you can find a link and just
throw it up on a thing one more time.
We're doing a little walk,
you know what I mean?
Just trying to get a little kind of
thing started. And uh, you know, uh,
this next song is kind of about learning
my wife and myself learning about this
and how we dealt with it.
And um,
it's called 65 roses and it's cost 65
roses because when children try to say
cystic fibrosis,
it often comes out sounding like 65 roses.
So a lot of the organizations are,
are kind of revolve around that theme.
But this song is just, it
seemed fitting title, you know,
[inaudible]
men.
A bit of wow.
Census singing and smash
man too long, baby. Who,
what went wrong to me?
How it got spoiled, Tim,
when he went back,
had to get back towns we had,
we were both young,
not spirits were behold.
Now we're just saying
green. We act like, oh,
we can't even talk it out.
That one of us walking way.
[inaudible]
when you reteach agist turns one in.
That spreads out the coffin.
Girly. You was so fan.
Huge was brand new.
World did see with some other woman,
but I was thinking you knew how it hurts.
Knew Howard knew how at Aes,
because the hog never heals,
was so busy screaming.
Don't hear the words that we say.
[inaudible]
we've taken our lumps,
which took a few blow.
We hit a few bombs had off fair share,
Chad,
to see through all of the bag,
but on us smells and rich hair.
We're not saying you got a bit south.
Gotta be strong.
Gotta be right.
Can't afford to be wrong.
It's hard to shake the
blues when you [inaudible]
worry too much for one cup of the bear.
Conga so much for one person to care.
We're fooling our families with food now.
Read pain.
Frustration is hope is a chance.
Who was a journey full drug,
maybe hopes of vaccine
in a race against time.
I can get down on my knees and pray.
Shouted the devil, Matt, Kirsten,
low Rambus them everything I can afford
at sell off mass sold that land to see
Chad to be righteous.
Tragically very of it.
You can't call them my outlook.
I stare with those
beautiful all of my problem.
Who's seen Milton way?
[inaudible]
the smile on her face,
daddy ever thing is
[inaudible]
police against him. I get
down home man. And uh,
very
awesome.
Wow Brian.
Thank you. Does beautiful man. How did,
how did you change from being
essentially like a rap guy?
You know when you came
out with a house of pain,
you were like a rapper and then you
became like this blues dude along the way.
You know, I think you fucked
a lot of people's heads up,
but that Whitey Ford Shit,
you know,
like a lot of people didn't see that
coming when you came out with what it's
like a lot of people were like,
whoa.
Um, a lot of it had to
do with, uh, you know,
a good friend just encouraging
me once he heard me doing it,
like I used to always
play guitar and stuff on,
just kind of on the low and the right
little ditties and I was recording.
I live house of pain and was according
with the homeboy and mine and he was home
produced a record. This guy, Dante Ross,
and he heard me strumming out what
actually became what it's like just in his
living room. I was playing a guitar and
he was like, what is that? And I, and,
and he was like,
we're going to record it and not
trusted him enough to believe it. Okay,
let's go for it. Wow. And did you feel
like you were pigeonholed as a rapper?
That people wouldn't accept it or we, we
think of, well, am I remember the label,
the label, Dan, they hated it. They
were, they didn't, they didn't,
but they thought I was really
fucking up. Really? Yeah.
They thought they thought it was really
doing the wrong thing, but you know, God,
they thought that thank God that I love
when people run like that. I love it.
So it's noetic and then I've just
fallen in love with writing songs.
You know what I mean?
I think all the time I've spent
as an MC and writing lyrics as a,
as a rapper has helped me learn
how to craft words in a way that,
you know, the song writing
is that much better for it.
That's true because a lot of rappers,
you know,
that's one things that rappers don't get
enough credit for is the complexity of
their versus and compared to a lot of
shit that you hear from just singers and
songwriters can tire song.
I just did a rapper might use that
many words in a one verse. Yeah,
we know what I mean. He
can't, not always. Well,
but what I'm saying is you have to learn
s through to use the words and use a
lot of them. And some not always
well but like look at Nas, you know?
But you know like,
and when you can be even more selective
about how many words it becomes easier
and no sore in a sense like,
oh,
I can choose less words and say more
because I'm singing and I'm playing this
tune with it, you know? Yeah. That's a,
that's an interesting place to come from
if you really think about it that way
because yeah, there's so many more words
in a rap song. Like I said, like I said,
especially not in us like a soldier
boy song. Do you consider that rap?
What is soldier boy so like,
you know,
and the things I'm familiar
with my hammer are,
are just kinda like chance
more than anything. Yeah.
It's funny how this shit goes, you know,
like that gets stuck in the rap genre.
But I mean little John made a career
doing that. He wasn't a rat rapper,
like come up with good
catch little phrases.
And have like eight of 'em on a song,
you know and know and people scream out
when they're drunk and a club mother,
fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah,
we'll host song like that.
You know what I mean? Hey,
if you want on soldier boy with, there's
cats that have been doing it before him,
you know? Right. So what did the label
should money. Anybody gets money.
Good for you. Good money,
good money. What did a,
would the labels say?
They couldn't say much?
I was luckily have kind of a big fish
on a small label. You know what I mean?
Anybody pull you aside and go,
you're fucking up kid. No, I didn't.
They didn't do wound me aside.
He told me blatantly what they
thought the words would they chose.
We don't think we think you need to
choose whether you're a rapper or a singer
or it's two different projects.
They didn't think it was one project.
That's hilarious because
I was doing this like,
like what had happened was I
went to New York and was doing I,
I quit house of pain basically in
thought I was over. I was just like,
music's over now. What do I mean? I mean
really come on. What am I going to do now?
I just was kind of down and
my buddy called me and said
screw everything to hell
with labels and what not.
Come to New York and make some music.
And I went out there strictly
to make a hip hop records.
So I made all these hip hop so every,
all the hip hop songs on that
Whitey force record. We're done.
First they were done and then the other
stuff started happening and we were just
like, just between me and Jonathan,
we kind of were like disco work.
If we piece it together. Right.
It makes kind of sense, you know,
and just made sense to us.
Yeah, I remember I heard why
it's lagging. I went, Whoa,
I get this mother fucker.
You uh,
took a crazy chance. God, it
was the best shit you did.
Even though my huge house of Payne Fan,
I love that.
But I like your singing better man.
I mean jump around at all time.
Classic period. Always will be
there. Louie Louie of the 90s.
When Marcus Davis used to fight in
the UFC. One of the things I loved,
you'd come out to chomp around
with a fucking killed on. Yeah.
Some other dudes need
to come out to that man.
I'd say that's a hype up fight music.
We need some more Irish fighters.
I remember the one that you teamed up
with Santana, I it or what's it called?
Put, put your lights on. Yeah. That was
one of my favorite James back in the day.
And that's what really made me
go, fuck. Yeah. He, you're legit.
That was, that was a good hookup. How'd
you, I mean, did you, how did you meet?
How did that ever come across?
It's
kind of crazy cause uh,
basically what happened is I recorded
that whole Whitey Ford record than this
heart thing happened.
And I wound up getting surgery,
like emergency surgery and
woke up from it. And um,
found out that I,
you know,
I had canceled my medical insurance
because I have my accountant at the time.
It ripped me off for like
couple hundred grand in taxes.
And so like I woke up from heart surgery,
like what my house,
like basically on the blocks and the
government calling me for money and I was
in my house,
it was in Laurel Canyon
in a Mount Olympus and uh,
it was on the hill.
You could see the whole city and the
house was empty except for me in a chair
and I was moving into a little apartment
like it was, it was, it was good,
humble tack. But I was spending
the last night in this house,
like looking out as the sun was going
down and I had a guitar and I started
writing the song and all,
that's what that's saying is that hey,
now all you sinners,
the lights were going,
the sun was going down on the city and
all the lights of the city were coming on
and it was like, Hey, now you soon as,
what's your lights on? The craziest thing.
As I just told his story at
one of these acoustic things,
it's something to kind of,
I realized recently that I
never really talk about much,
but like when I was in the
hospital after this surgery,
like I think hospitals kill
more people than anything. Um,
from my experience as much as the surgeon
saved my life in his tent and all that,
the hospital damn near killed me.
What do you mean they didn't,
you don't rest in a hospital. They tell
you get rest, you know this, but every,
every other minute somebody coming in
and sticking a needle in you and it's
never with it's, and even in
a great hospital, you know,
I was in a great hospital is probably
one of the best hospitals in the world.
It's still like, it's not nurses
that do these things anymore.
There's like sub sub sub nurses,
nurses,
that's all they do is come and take
blood from everybody who goes around with
his tray everyday.
And,
but every minute you're always getting
poked and prodded and they're doing
something to you in that
telling you what it is.
And like I didn't even get explained
about the thing ticking in my chest until
like two days after I woke up.
Like I'm just,
I was going nuts from hearing the sound.
I thought,
I think I told this story last
time about a telltale heart.
I was like going nuts. So, but basically
there's, you hear that all day,
all day. It's like white noise to me
now. But yeah, I could take my pulse.
Just put that shit up to the mic again.
People who haven't heard this
need to hear this. That's
it's so crazy. Wow. That's,
that's some real shit.
So one of the nights like I was only,
I only stayed there like six days.
I was supposed to be there
like couple of weeks,
but like they let me go home
cause I was gonna I was losing it.
I was going to die. Nobody will
let you sleep. It wouldn't,
they just wouldn't let me rest and
I was losing, I thought I just,
I was convinced I was going to die
in the hospital basically. Wow.
But the night before they let me go.
I was losing it.
I mean like that kind of tears where
they're just coming out of your eyes and a
woman came in this nurse and like was
the first person actually just such me
with some just humanity and care and be
like, oh, it's all right. It's all right.
It's all right. And so I was in, it
sued me enough that I fell asleep,
woke up the next day. I was able to get
out of the hospital. I got home. Wow.
Couple of weeks later when I was feeling
that's what I wasn't. I was like,
I want to go back and think
this nurse, you know what I
mean? Let's, you know what?
I made my,
my people take me to the hospital because
I was still like walking around freely.
Can I ask something?
Can I get something?
This person she didn't exist didn't exist.
Do you, he know that you
are the guy, the angel.
I knew by the way you said it the way
you said it was setting up a ghost story.
Well, I mean it's about
the song. There's an age,
there's a monster lives
sitting under my bed.
That was the noise of me
of me. Um, what is this?
This is what he's talking.
That was the noise, uh, of,
of the, of the heart of death.
And then the angel with her
hand on my head was the woman.
Yes.
This is a great fucking song.
Try that shit up.
[inaudible]
just say I got nothing
to be a [inaudible].
Still got a purpose to serve.
[inaudible]
damn. My hair was black. Yeah. Isn't
that crazy? When you see a white man,
it's weird seeing yourself agent that did.
That is a crazy look white now.
Wow.
That's crazy.
It's nuts.
Seen that song.
Yeah. I constantly have to dye my hair
and my, that's what my kitchen looks like.
Fucking like where you splatter a
little bit on your toilet or on your,
on your wall and sit down. At least it
looks like there's blood everywhere.
And My, my path, I just got to own it,
man. I can't, I can't just, yes. For
mania, man. That's it. I mean, what am I
gonna do with the beard man? It's right.
Yeah. A lot of life. If he likes
it anyway, to me and wife, he it.
A lot of guys get in there with a brush
and do the whole beard. Ah, I'm go, oh my,
Oh, I earned every one of
these man. Indeed. Indeed.
And I know I'm 42 this is like,
remember I've had heart surgeries.
I've live eight life so far.
Man. I'm good hearing that song.
Knowing that story, it makes it
so much different. It's amazing.
It's amazing how much it fires you
up, dude. You were at that. That's,
that is the root of all fucking brilliance
and creativity is a man with his back
pushed against the wall or just fires
back. That's the best shit. That's the,
that was rough time. That God song is
just one of your best songs ever. I mean,
you've got a lot of great fucking
songs, but that's one of, that's a,
that's an all timer,
bro. That's an all timer.
And when you think about
where it came from, you know,
do you ever work with Santana anymore?
I, I haven't heard from him, you know,
quite a while. But how Tom is your
old label feel TM, right? Fuck no,
they're not in business anymore.
That's so whoever the asshole was,
it actually said to you as a bad
idea when that song came out,
boy did that do feel stupid. That
record sold a lot of records, man.
Is that guy still in the music business?
That fucking dummy that
gave you shitty advice.
It's always amazing when
someone who's not up.
He's on some like real Deepak Chopra type
shit now. Oh, he's like turned in one.
He made, I mean I made him good $40
million, man. So whoa. You know,
it's a lot of money.
You know,
saw the guy 4 million records and that's
not counting the house of pain records.
That's another car. Three or 4 million
records. That's a lot of records.
Yeah, that's pretty good. Some people
who sold them out more, but I ain't mad.
I ain't sneeze and that you
don't want to be number one man.
He just want to be able to buy those
Audis and just chill. I like my life.
Like I've always told people I like that
the music is more famous than my face,
man. I really do. Fuck yeah, that's
what I say about Steve. What's his name?
Cause I'm going to the olive bar like
right at the Ralph's down the street after
this and get me some olives and some
crackers and like nobody will bother me.
Yeah, you could sneak Steve Miller.
Nobody knows who Steve Miller looks like.
Not a person alive that knows a
Steve Miller. Looks like they've got,
could be anywhere. Yeah. He, Mick
Jagger can't go anywhere. You know,
not that Steve Miller had ever reached
the status of the rolling stones,
but pretty God damn successful.
You know, he ain't man,
I ain't mad.
Really hang out at the bar in her.
I don't hang out and not olive garden.
The olive bar at Ralph's like that where
you have all of exotic olives. Okay.
Get all, I'd like, I'll
heard olive garden. You just
heard all and like I said,
all the bar,
there's that all of uh,
there's all of bar also like, or like
just a place that's an olive bar. Yeah,
it's called the all time actually,
but I always call it the olive bar.
Oh,
it's a restaurant bar that's in Toluca
Lake is all into olives and stuff like
that. It's got everything. It's like
a little whole foods mixed with a bar.
I'd have to go check that. A whole foods
in a bar together at the restaurant,
like that kind of food.
You know that good please to pick
up vegan chicks.
Oh,
that's where all the actresses hang out
and just sit there and eat healthy and
I'm in a de Bouley. What's up? I'm in the
olives man. They're like, oh dude. Yeah.
What's that about? I don't know if I
can tell you about that. Tastes good.
I do look on, all of us are disgusting
and it's funny that the WWE,
I love the album, but I hate olives.
Why do you hate olives? They're gross.
Have boils. Fantastic for you.
Did you always like olives?
Did you guys always up?
I think that's one of those things
that come later in your life where you
started liking?
No, no. I might dare. I liked him when
I was young. I think I just, you know,
I like a lot of weird shit though.
I like starts thirties loves,
I don't like sardines. I like anchovies.
Nah, no, I like them like you know,
crushed into like flavors I couldn't eat.
Just the anchovy don't like,
I'm not opposed to some of those things
used as ingredients and other things.
I'll eat a half a pound of
anchovies in a setting. Wow.
Will you put it on like a big hunk of
bread and make a sandwich out of the war?
She had doctor's orders to stop
faces and eyes and all I need. Uh,
they told me to stop beating sardines
cause I had arsenic poison. Wow.
Cause I was eating so many sardines.
Sardines are just dirty juice.
Apple juice and grape juice. Yam. I
was like, I was talking to my wife,
why don't we ever give her apple juice?
And it's like,
cause there's arsenic in it and she
googled it up and show me grape juice and
apple juice. Wow. You know the,
the metals, the heavy metals is,
it's pollution. That's how the, uh,
that's how the sardines absorbed.
That's where the flavor comes
from. Now, pollution. Yeah.
If you think about what lobsters are,
man,
lobsters are the dirtiest
bottom feeders of all time.
They taste delicious
shrimp too. Yeah, exactly.
Do you know what they used
to be like in New York?
Lobsters were like poor people food.
It's like there were so common they
used to like get them out of the Hudson
river like way back in the day
and they would serve him at bars.
That's like they would, the big thing
that people would serve peanuts.
What would it be like? Normal bar
food. Like instead of a burger,
you get a lobster.
It was like poor people food.
Easy to cook the throat and boiling water.
People crack it open and
well, fuck. Look at wood floors.
That used to be for poor people yet
carpet if you had money, you know,
and now I'm ripping out carpet and
sing this wood floor that did that.
That just has glue and fucking
hammers and staples in it.
They don't give a shit because back then
they were like costing. What's that?
Carpet is nasty. Nasty. It's like never
changed her fucking clothes. One of the
things about like,
you know,
I live in with this cystic fibrosis
thing as we ought to be very,
she can't get a cold.
I got a two and a half year old daughter.
Never had a sniffle.
Like a thing about that you have kids,
do you have them monitor their
diet like oh well you have to,
I mean actually no, no, no. With that,
with cystic fibrosis it's a constant
struggle to keep weight on them.
So you're fasting, you're putting, you're
loading up fats and and stuff like that.
Yeah, it's, it's absolutely
new. Our daughter who is like,
actually that's her only thing she
struggling with is a little bit of weight
we're trying to get,
you know.
But she's like that stage where she just
so ran two and a half ran buses and her
appetite just isn't huge. And
it's like we have, you know,
it's a constant battle to try and get,
get the weight on her.
You have specific high caloric
foods that you use server.
We just load a lot of things up with
extra butters and olive oils and you know,
and my wife is constantly,
we have two different things like
what we eat and watch what she eats.
You know what I mean?
Like she gets the full fat of everything
with the highest calories and we try
and eat more of a, you know,
lower fat kind of, you know,
server like Colby beef and stuff along
those lines. Well she started at what?
Right for a while she would
only eat like two things, man,
macaroni and cheese and chicken nuggets
and now she's starting to develop
actually tastes for other things.
I could stitch like a brilliant day
when we can get her to eat a burrito and
she'd like likes it and like,
you know,
get these new things because she's
starting to get more interested in food
hopefully. And what are the
treatments? What are they,
what do they do for right now our does,
she's doing very well.
She has no mucus in her lungs.
Her lungs are functioning at
99.9 plus, you know, percentage,
which is awesome. But she's
still, we put her on a, in a vast,
that's hooks to a compressor
that basically just
kind of violently shakes her,
you know,
and basically what the premise of that
is when the music mucus does form in
these people's lungs,
it shakes it loose so they can
expectorated a lot easier. And um,
so besides that she did little albuterol
like, you know, Kinda like, you know,
same as kind of asthma
right now just for us,
it's all preventative at the moment. You
know, our biggest struggle, like I said,
is, is just keeping weight on her. Wow.
Just getting her to gain and
gang because she's, you know,
she's very tall for her age,
but she's very thin and she
needs to be heavier because it,
it'll help the lung development developed
that much healthier. You know, Brian,
your friend Mc Chris also was
involved in helping. Yeah, I've been,
I've been getting a lot of messages
about me and this dude should link up
somehow. Great. He's a great guy.
And Brian just did a podcast
with him and tell me,
what did he say Brian About cystic
fibrosis? I know that he's a,
well, he's calm. He's been, he's,
he's amazing. He's, I, I think it's,
I believe it's his niece
is, uh, has it. And so far,
the longest time he's been
doing these, uh, you know,
shows and he's been doing ebay auctions
and stuff in and be good always website
also. He has ways that you
can help, uh, help the cause.
And I asked him the other day how much
he's raising. He's, I mean, he's just,
you know, a white rapper,
nerd rapper, and he's almost,
I think he said almost
$100,000. He said, yeah,
I listened to that part of your podcast.
And there was,
what was the name of that podcast
on, what do you call it? A,
we haven't made a name of it,
we're thinking muff said,
or if it's going to be released on
death squad in the next couple of days.
So you haven't even named it yet.
Now we're asking in the,
in the actual episode what we should
name it. And there's like, you know,
a lot of weird things, but what it
is, it's a comic books. Uh, with me,
Ryan Kelly talking with comic books.
We had a guy that worked at marvel
and Ryan steely is a porn star. Yeah.
Penthouse pet. Did you know there's
lot other, the artists we had,
he works on both marvel
and DC at the same time.
And he does like Conan and Batman.
That's awesome. And stuff like that.
He's bad ass, but we're going to,
what's his name? Uh, Shit you call me.
I've got Dan. Uh, but he, he does this
thing called drink a drink and draw,
which is a new thing that
blue with a draw something,
it's a really popular
app that's on the iPhone,
but he has been doing it at bars where
you just go and you just hang out with a
bunch of people and you all just
get drunk and draw at the same time.
And now they have it.
Citywide were like,
these guys like meet up and like these
artists and they just sit there and meet
each other and then they hang out and
started drawing shit on an iPhone. Oh No,
no, no, no phones. Just an APP to
get them together. No, no, but,
but with the popularity of that and
it's something that he's been doing,
what I was saying is that there's a
popular app right now that you're pretty
much playing, win, lose, or draw with
each other and that's so big right now.
But he's been doing it. Yeah,
it was that pretty late.
It's so buggy.
It doesn't seem like they're finished
with [inaudible] words on there. Yeah,
I know. It's like eight words.
I'm confused. All right. He,
he's working on something where they get
together and they draw. Yeah, like, like,
like stuff. There's a lot of, yeah,
there's a lot of cities that are doing
this where you go to like these bars and
just hang. His name is Dan.
He's urban barbarian at Twitter.
It's called drinker draw and it's just
cool. He does hang out and get drunk and,
and meet people and you draw and sometimes
you have like a little missions and
stuff. I'm not really sure how
it works. I haven't done it yet.
So everybody goes to a bar and
they just bring paper. Yeah,
they just start drawing.
Yeah.
And they start drawing and it's really
cool if you go to his Twitter page,
he has a bunch of shit, but
here, let me show you something.
He's done like a Batman drawing that he's
done that it's going to blow your mind
and like how good it sounds like it
would be hard to find so many people that
are really into drawing,
get together at a bro.
It's that many people that good
at it. Yeah. Drawing is hard.
It's gotten so big that it's
actually, you know, it's, it's,
it's in multiple cities now.
It's actually catching on pretty big
and with a slight cartooning karaoke or
something. Exactly. That's funny.
That's a really good way of putting it.
Here's this website. Check out this
drawing he just did the other day.
I drink her draw. I've of the
dark night, you know? Yeah.
That's some shit I did when I was 15 it's
crazy too. They're kind of shit. Yeah.
Imagine doing that, getting drunk. Well,
you're obviously not going to do it,
but I would do it. I still draw, dude.
I just draw a lot. That's pretty good.
He's very good obviously. Yeah, but no,
I mean if I was into comic book art,
if I was like really into drawing,
it'd be a fun fucking thing to do.
I'm sure you know a lot of people find
going out and hanging out with people.
That's pretty cool. A lot of people
find going out and going to bars,
like oftentimes it's
pretty fucking boring.
And this guy is a huge fan of
the Joe Rogan Rogan podcast.
He was at a big fan. He was so happy to
be here at the studio. Oh, that's cool.
He's a big MMA fan,
but we had him and Mc Chris on the show.
It's going to be released next day or two
and it's a probably a called something
like the warp zone or MF senators until
your boy. And He's good at me too.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
What is that a, what's that one image
that you were just showing the one down,
right? Yeah, right there. You just
have the cursor. Yeah. What is that?
Uh, this is, it looks like a c
urban barbarian. He's got to look
like a liquor bottle. It says.
Yeah, that's his Twitter name.
He just tagged it. But he does,
if you go to his website, oh,
here's one. He did a madmen. Uh,
he's done a lot of video game covers.
He's also done like a lot of different
random things also like movie posters and
Shit. Just talented as fuck. Yeah. I used
to love comic books room, but I, I just,
I've tried getting into him as an adult
and for whatever reason I just get,
well I tell you the walking dead wants
pretty fucking good. That's what I hear.
I just, I don't know. I can't get
myself to the store to buy it.
You know what I did though?
I did get an APP on, um,
I wonder if I can get the walking dead on
my iPad. You care. That's how I read it.
The, I got to, oh, by the way, I got
the new iPad. Me Now got the new,
I've had three over here.
What are you doing with that?
You're fucking making loans on
their file because I wanted the, uh,
the four g hotspot.
And what's crazy is,
is that I did a speed test on it and
it was actually faster than the $120
Internet that I have here at the
studio. Uh, the speech was quick,
quicker on my iPad than it was Jose
talking charter business grades,
uh, Internet. I don't lose your, your,
I got the Verizon, uh, iPad. Yeah,
the Verizon. So right now I'm on LTE
network is what it says on there.
And I have a digital hot spot and
now I could have all my shit on that.
Of course you're paying for the bandwidth.
So they don't have like
unlimited bandwidth.
I have a card that it's a
Verizon on tour with the iPhone.
Sometimes I would just
make my own little hotspot.
They kill you after a couple of days
of that, they start hollering messages.
Oh yeah, you're going over. Right.
It's amazing how little bandwidth you
can actually use. I've got a four g card,
I put it in my laptop,
I downloaded one movie and they'll set,
I'd use 75% of my bandwidth for the month.
So they send you messages and stuff.
So, yeah, the secret is
just don't do videos,
but if you do anything else but videos,
you should be fine. You know, like,
like even youtube videos,
just wait till you get home because
you're going to just kill it.
I bet your upstream is not as
good though, right? Probably not.
My upstream was faster than the charter
here. Really? It was only eight.
I have a screenshot of it right now.
I could tweet, I'll tweet it later.
But it's incredible. Yeah. So
you really happy with that? Yeah.
It was called the screen resolution.
I didn't think I was just going to notice
a huge difference because this is the
retina display and stuff like
that. Uh, it's totally noticeable,
but when I hold up both my iPad two
and the iPad three together, it's,
it's night and day different.
So that,
that was bigger than I
thought it was a speed wise.
I don't really notice any
kind of speed difference. Uh,
it's not overheating a lot of reports.
I've been saying that the new iPads
overheating because it's got like so many
dual processors in the retina
display and all this shit.
But I haven't had any problems with it.
Right over your deck and go scrolling.
Yeah. That's what happens, right. They get
hot. Yeah. Kill your sperm and you don't,
you know,
there's a big thing that lie to people
don't talk about is generic batteries
exploding. And I didn't know about
this until I went on Amazon in the,
if he looks at some of the comments,
if you like buy a generic camera
for a cam quarter, you know,
instead of Saturday for battery,
these cheaply made batteries
explode all the time.
Somebody even like, like
commented me on at, uh,
something I was talking
about in the past that I do,
don't buy the cheap version of this.
Look what happened to me.
And he showed me his pictures of his bed
where he was in his bed with his laptop
and he had a generic battery
in it and it blew up in his,
in his bed and it's just blackness
all around his pillow. And I was like,
Holy Shit, that actually happened to you?
And he goes, yeah dude, don't buy the gin.
Don't buy that generic shit.
Yeah, they do blow up, man.
You'll hear about batteries blowing up.
It was actually a case for your iPhone.
I'm sorry.
Now I laptop.
It was one of those battery extended
battery cases and I was going to buy the
mophie one and then he's like,
eh, but then I was like, well,
I can save $50 by by this generic
wine. He's like, don't buy that shirt.
I actually was rocking at morphing
one for awhile. I'm broke.
I got to send it back. Did the
really? Yup. What happened? Stop war.
Just stopped working and drop it a few
times. No, never dropped it or anything,
but if you look at the comments,
that's one of the biggest things
for those mofi cases. It's like, ah,
the thing breaks off where you have to
charge it or it stopped working so it's
not that durable. It's not that durable.
Have you seen that new phone? The,
it's called the galaxy
note. It's 5.3 inches. Yeah.
It's like this fucking bit.
It's enormous.
It's like it's a cross between
like a tablet and a phone.
They're coming out with another
iPhone, iPad. Supposedly.
That's going to be that like that.
Like a smaller version,
like a seven inch version. But
it's not a phone. No, no, no, no.
I got a phone with the high.
Yeah,
this has a stylist and you could write
on photos or you can write like I'm with
stupid and put an Arrow and then
put that shit up on Twitter.
I mean it's the right on the photo.
You take a photo with it.
It's like an eight minute that on the IPAD
and I can do that on my iPhone. Right?
Yeah. You can write scribble on it,
man. I'm a killer on the iPhone dude.
How do you write with, what do you
write with [inaudible]? You can use it.
A lot of different programs at the one
I use on the iPad for doing that exact
same thing is called pen. Uh, hold
on, let me look at, you use a stylist,
these your finger. Uh, I have a
stylist but I never use it. I do.
You do use your coke fingernail?
It's called pen pencil to
meet or something like that.
And there's also one color box HD,
which is my new favorite drawing. Oh,
so you can do the same thing.
It just won't happen.
Just take a photo or take it from your
library, throw it on there tweeting.
Some dude brought it to Louisville and
I swear for two whole seconds I really
thought I was on acid. The guy had this
camera and he was coming at me with this,
this phone out of my test on a
tablet and that's not a camera.
That's not a phone. What the fuck is that
like? I really thought I was on acid.
The phone was so big. I was like,
this is beyond the looking glass.
I'm Alice in wonderland.
You know? I'm like,
I'm like looking at a table that's the
size of the moon. I was looking at this.
They go like that.
Gabby.
I think the IPAD or the iPhone
five when it gets announced,
probably in June or or so.
I think that's going to be something
similar to that where it's maybe not that
big, but I really think that it's probably
going to be from wall to wall screen.
Maybe a teeny bit bigger and skinny.
Maybe somebody had liked the size
of this the way it is. I mean,
not a lot of whole lot of people complain
except people that are really into
media applications and you can always
get an android man. All right. That um,
I'll tell you though,
that new a ice cream sandwich,
the new operating system on Android
is pretty fucking dope dude.
It's pretty wild there.
There's more people using androids
now than are even using iPhones.
But I think the APP markets not as big in
the malware market is through the roof.
Way more fake shit and malware and
viruses and the nonsense for androids.
Everybody who opposed to
something on Instagram for her,
cause they apparently just let
android join Instagram. Right.
He posted a picture, he's like,
here's for you android users.
And it was a toilet with a bunch of gold.
That was pretty funny.
A toilet with a bunch of gold fixtures.
Here's a toilet with a bunch of gold
fixtures for all you and bite you.
I don't get it. Android is a toilet with
a bunch of gold fixtures. Oh, I see.
What you're saying. I thought
it was funny as now, you know,
I'm I rock iPhone because
I liked the lenses.
My Buddy and rented show show him this.
He was showing me this,
I'm going to freak the fuck out.
I need to get one of these.
A friend of mine's father apparently
invented this thing called Ipro lands is
this case starts with a case and
then has this like handle that.
You can kind of make until almost
a steady cam kind of thing. What?
And you just screw on there.
But then there's a,
a wide angle in a fish islands bill
into the handle to handle that is like
there's two of them. Take my word
for it. You just pull it off,
you snap it on and now you got a crazy
fish islands and we were taking pictures
earlier, uh, with it and it's
perfect. Like the dirt, the
quality lens is actually,
I would say I always saw those,
but we really had one of those is his law,
his buddy's dad. It's a,
both a mutual friend of ours,
like basically the Lux model
with the handle and shit.
[inaudible] have the handle. He probably
just doesn't use it. Like I, I'm, I'm,
I'm always on the camera and running
around doing stuff for Instagram and
Instagram, which I love. I just signed up
today. Keeps me out of trouble man. Yeah,
just today, signed up doing
all kinds of edits. Oh Gee.
Everlast on both Twitter and Instagram.
Come Hollering Joe Rogan experience
on Instagram as a, to this a question.
I'll be your picture. By the way, the
first photo I ever uploaded on Intagram,
the one I took today. Oh, is
that right? In this studio?
Goddamn history was where you need to
attach my name to that told you you ever
lie. I don't know how to use
Instagram yet. I'm in the comments.
Just put at Ogm or now I'm a newb.
I just don't understand and
then I'll follow you right back.
I'll call me on that actually
in the comments are set.
I think I saw the Twitter.
Yeah. For Twitter. I'll do,
I have to one ball show ball.
Cause my name's Ed on both. Oh,
there you go. Well done. It happened.
I had already went down or
you want to do one more sign?
We'll get the fuck out of you can do one
more song, man. Let's do one more song.
I hold them. You know, we incorporate
it. Swim. Born your people to please.
All right. This is just a lot of
positives first. You know what?
You put that in the air and let me,
let me take a rag off of that
motherfucker right there and I'm gonna.
I'm gonna make it happen. I'm
going to go classic on you. Um,
he was now eating sugar cookies. I
stay out. Yeah. Think of sugar cookies.
Yeah.
I'll have some sugar cookies.
We live here. Yeah. Yeah,
we're live. Here we go. These gentlemen.
The one and only. Oh Gee. Everlast
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
lousy man in Gusto.
Slowly change the hair on his face.
Dirty traitor locked down.
Pull the main.
Yes ma'am. Good. Cusper Shaman is, I
get a job.
You fogging slabs out here.
You Buy Gab B.
You ever had wow.
Marianne
[inaudible] saying
[inaudible].
Huh?
[inaudible]
Nerium and wounded slang.
mayor got paid back in named time,
told see the Wu bad thing
down may man dreaming now,
three months later.
See one day to all the cow
swear God damn fan man man could now bow
get some stay woke up through the doe.
You eat a choleric killer
cow who said the cow
gabble be you ever had wow man in his
[inaudible] they have to chew
Nerium man.
[inaudible] man
[inaudible] like
new [inaudible]
seen Richman man. I seen a good
man seeing scene itself, man.
Crime scene and losing.
We hand sad man greenhorn and numbness
man that seeing the good side of bed.
Dan's side of never thing between late
silver spoon drank from the Golden Cup.
Smoke ban is green.
Stone bad is dabs and Liza cover
its ass for group day. Haha.
You knew it in usually depends always stop
this kid named maxis to get
fast snacks on the corner.
Who drives in that hay
out that kitchen phase.
Keep pace with
today.
One that there was a big
gun fatmax louses here.
Cool down is chrome and
Pfaff tops and shit wound up
as laughing.
His kid [inaudible] his pain.
He knew coma down. We fast.
What they say when lady gay
gap had Wogo here that new
[inaudible] [inaudible]
David,
him and his life
navy man would its day.
Huh?
Navy man.
[inaudible]
yeah.
Powerful. Everlast dude, that was
awesome man. Thank you very much.
Anytime dog. I'll come back every
week dog. Too much fun dude.
You're the best man having you
on so much fun. It's so cool.
Do you want to be roommates?
He's got a bromance going, you
know, got, got to do the bromance,
the wings on it.
Don't put the wings on to,
we could totally do this way more
often. People love you. Aww, I love you.
I'm so happy. You know, mandate. A lot
of love came through the podcast man and,
and you know,
if you got an extra buck,
if you don't, it's all good.
You got to ask you again. Um,
I don't know the link off hand,
but uh,
just hope that y'all will tweet
it out again. It's the cff.org.
There's a great strides.
Is the name of the organization where
the Schrody family team, um, you know,
that's, that's, you know, you know,
we were trying to get our team,
obviously the donations,
but even if, you know,
if you just sent them a donation that's
fine too. But we got, you know, we're,
this is a little walk we sponsor
every year and, and you know,
we liked doing it and I said,
yeah, like I said, I got,
I'm be hitting you up in a lot
of other cats, you know, for,
in the future we're going to try and put
together some events and really do some,
I'll do anything to get this thing wiped
out in the next five years and then
we'll move onto the next thing. And this
is all a lot of privately financed. Yeah.
There's no government funding
whatsoever for it, man.
It's complete private donations and
it's also ranked like as one of the top
charities in the world
as far as getting like,
it's the high 80th percentile on how
much every of every dollar gets into the
researchers actual. When you
are so closely, uh, you know,
you're so closely involved
with something like this.
Does this drive you crazy when
you see like that Coney Shit?
Like you know when you yo, no,
no because you know, I mean it's,
it's not a horrible thing for
everybody to jump on the bandwagon of,
you know what I mean? The back does a
cystic fibrosis is such a rare thing,
you know what I mean? It's like my, my,
in order for my daughter to have it,
both I and my wife had to be quote
unquote carriers of this. We had no idea,
cause I've looked back through generations
of my family and generation of hers
and it has to be both. It has to be
both. If there's one of us that didn't,
it will, it will. And you know,
there's, if I have more children,
there's a one in four chance that
that child will have cystic fibrosis.
So that's a, that's a whole nother
thing. But no, it doesn't bother me man.
There's room for every, you
know, everything needs help.
I mean like honestly I'm at that
is a scandal involving the call,
the dualistic guy who ripped
off a lot of people. Oh No.
Huge percentage of the money
went to him and his organization.
Is that why they found him naked
in the like crazy. That's a shame.
That's a shame. Well, my attitude in
general is like, look man, this is,
this is my priority.
I don't expect the guy out there who
maybe he's might be dealing with a child
with something else cancer or, or down
syndrome. I expect them to, to just,
I'm doing my part and I'm saying,
Hey,
if you got an extra 50 cents and and
missing and five songs for you today,
maybe touched you a little something.
You know,
I just the other day from
throwing it down on Twitter,
a couple thousand dollars from complete
strangers and there was a lot of $1
there was and you know what? Don't
think that doesn't make a difference.
That's appreciate.
I know how hard times are that $1 debt.
That means not even more. There's people
who get $500 I was tripping. I was like,
these are strangers, man. You
know, and I wrote on Twitter,
the kindness of strangers
is, you know, overwhelming.
It's beautiful times and it
makes them feel so good to,
people don't know if they've
never donated something like that.
If you really want to, this is something
we could, I'm, I honestly believe in the,
and there's things going on
right now. This thing can
be, it's a genetic disorder.
So technically you can't really,
all you can do is treat it,
but they can treat it to the
point where it's nullified.
And that can happen in our lifetime
and these kids won't be dying in their
thirties.
And you know that up until recently,
the median life span is 35.
Wow. And so that's, you know,
and that's what I read instantly
when my child was diagnosed.
But it's changing every day right now
because the science every day is getting
so much better.
So we don't know now because we haven't
seen what these effects of had on these
youngsters, man. So I mean, I'm,
I'm guarantee you that you would,
did lifespans are already being,
being increased daily.
But this thing could be like put to
bed honestly within the next 10 years.
If the right money and the right things
are found in it and it's one of them
things, it's one of them. It's like
such a complex genetic thing. I,
I'm not gonna try and s tell you details
about it because I'll sound like a
Maura, but it's one of them things
that attracts the most brilliant minds.
It's one of the puzzles that the most
brilliant dudes want to figure out as far
as into medical fields. You, you get
the cream of the crop. And like I said,
cff.org is one of the organizations like
88 85 to 89% sign of every dollar is
getting to the researchers. It's not,
it's not getting chopped up and you know,
they, they're documented is one of
the best charities in that sense.
That's beautiful. See F F. Dot. Org folks,
we're going to put this great strides.
You know,
there's walks all over the country too.
You could start your own team and,
and raise your own bread and you know,
if anybody feels like doing it,
you know,
and I saying we're going to have concerts
and we're going to do all kinds of
things. But right now that
we're sponsoring this walk,
I'm in F. Dot. Org folks, uh,
yet we're going to put it on Twitter too.
If you forget it from today,
if you're listening in your car,
put a direct link to the Schrody family
teams so you could dedicated or like you
know in the name of Layla are beautiful,
healthy, so far a young daughter and,
and hope to keep her that way.
Yes,
we'll throw that up on Twitter
and we'll get as many people
and thanks for all the love. And literally
last time I came on I got more love.
I've never, ever, I've done a lot of
shows, I've done a lot of things do.
I have never seen the reaction I
saw for coming on the show. This
is a, this is a beautiful
group of people out there, man.
A Beautiful Group of people
that have tuned into this
show. And I don't, you know,
I don't know how it all
happened, but, uh, I feel very,
very fortunate and I think
Brian feels the same.
It might have something to do with
all those cookies, sugar, cookies,
sugar cookies are motherfucker,
man, real hard to tune into it.
We're trying real hard to
tune into it and we want to,
we want everybody else to
tune into it to together.
I believe that we can truly be a better
group of human beings. All of us can win,
absolutely. Buyer each other.
We push each other forward.
And if you get enough people that
think a certain way, it doesn't,
you don't lose hope. You
do know that there's people
out there that got it wrong,
but there's also people there that got
it right. You could find them. You know,
you could live your life like a Goddamn
episode of Nancy Grace and only look for
the shittiest things every goddamn day
and really freak yourself the fuck out.
And that's, that's true and real.
Or You could live your life.
We need together a lot
of money, man, and make
a network and just have it be the
good news network. Yeah, no shit.
I bet you would be a huge success,
man. Yeah, exactly. We will.
We have 7 billion people on this planet.
We concentrate on the most horrific
thing. There's a lot of good news, man.
You wouldn't know it. You're right.
You're right. And that would,
that would feel good news.
How would you,
if you came home from the end of the day,
wouldn't you?
Wouldn't you just be glad to be like,
let me just see some good
shit happening in the world.
Turn that on for 45 minutes.
Exactly.
We were constantly afraid of danger.
We have information that's
coming to us from places we'll,
we'll never physically be and
yet we'll still worry about it.
And I bet you there's good
news from those places too,
that we're not being told bad. Yeah.
Motherfuckers keep us in the dark. Right.
Hey Gel. Um, can I say real quick?
Me and Joey Diaz are doing a short
little Midwest tour. Yeah. What is that?
It's now on sale. I, it's a may
17 two will be in Columbus, Ohio.
May 18th will be in Cleveland, Ohio. May
19th will be in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
You got a death squad.
Dot TV right at the top it says death
squad mini tour for all the links so that
tickets, me and Joey Diaz. That's awesome.
This is your first time on the road or
like with a comic life Joey too. Yeah,
just you and Joey and just me and joy.
Wow. How much time are you going to do?
Like 1520 and that Joe is going to just
go off for an hour and a good Joey.
A lot of those little five hour
energy drinks. He loves those as wow.
That's going to be fun. So what are the
places? Just it's on death squad TV. Yeah.
Death squad.tv.
We're playing the woodlands tavern,
that garage shop and the
Mullens in Pittsburgh. Oh,
so you're doing bars like
it's like stand up style,
like small menu music stuff too. That's
great stuff. It's going to be fun.
You're going to,
where was I was on tour.
We were somewhere and we went
to a restaurant and it was like,
you know how to half a bar? I'm like, we
were really good restaurant too. I can't,
I think it was in Chicago in Italian
spot and like a comic just started like,
I guess they were having a comedy night
and there's a few common standards just
like got up in front of
cats eating dinner and like,
I don't even think people were expecting
comics to be there. Like in there.
Maybe it was their girlfriend and they
just went at it and I was just like, man,
I don't think I could do that.
Uh, that's rough business man.
Trying to get a laugh out of cats that
it was like got a mouthful of food and
like looking at you like,
what the hell are you doing here?
And I've done that shit.
I used to do a waiting room.
I did it only once the GIG was canceled,
but it was a waiting room of a,
of a restaurant and this is the
first day they were going to have it.
It was a huge restaurant.
And what they had,
they had two big gigantic places in
Massachusetts, like down by the Cape.
They have these giant restaurants,
they're mad like preposterously big.
I did it again,
boom drink.
And in the middle of it there was like a
place where they would have a stage for
a band. So people would be like
waiting, like waiting for the table,
it'd be called. And you just go
on stage out of nowhere. I mean,
I don't even remember if a Dj introduced
me. I don't know what had happened. Um,
you know, telling these ridiculously
fucking dirty jokes, you know,
to a bunch of strangers and right when
you're about to hit the punchline Johnson
table of three year, your table's
ready. Can you come to the front?
It was on the same PA system.
That's my PA system for telling jokes
was on the same PA system as the tape.
It was.
That was,
that was one of the most ridiculous
like carrying us rough business.
Anybody who gets somewhere
in comedy, man, I just like,
I think it's referred in the fight
game, man. You got to have a particular,
you've got to have a particular sickness,
like a fight game.
If you're really truly talented,
you might only have to fight two
or three fights in some real shitty
organization. As a comic, you probably
got to like early on, dude. I mean like,
well there's some guys will tell you,
you should never get out
of a shitty situations.
You should always stay in the muck because
if you ever get too soft and get to a,
you know,
you only preach to the converted and
you don't go out and do like some sleazy
little places and seed. Second
Dingle. Yeah, there's a,
there's a very real vibe that
you get off a real small crowd.
It's a different vibe, especially a small
crowd. Dennis, totally different thing.
If I were to stroll into a bar and
start playing songs, it's not the same.
Even if it's total strangers dead
like you know, like say a dead call,
just show up and do it.
It's a totally different beings in your,
it'd be way more accepting of short music
in the background and listening to you
playing. I'd be like, Oh yeah.
Then like you're engaging people
as a community and like directly,
like I want you to laugh at what
I'm saying. It's very arrogant to,
and most people,
you know,
you see a person there on stage and your
first reaction is why should you be the
guy talking? What you that I'm
going to give up the position.
I'm going to sit back and just let you
run my thoughts with your loud amplified
mouth.
That's offensive,
especially when you're not very good at
it and when you wanted to just go to a
bar and have a drink and some
fucking guy who was not very good,
it's up there saying a
bunch of shitty jokes, man.
That's how we learn how to do it
takes balls of steel man, very tart.
It doesn't matter how good you are.
It takes balls of steel. The fry,
it's a fun Gig. It's a Joey Diaz
says. He said it's the hardest,
easiest thing you'll ever do.
That's the best way to describe it.
I think if you get good at it,
it becomes easy. It becomes fun,
but it's hard to stay up. It's
hard to stay good. It's hard to
stay in that frequency, you
know? Yeah. That's, that's
true of a lot of stuff. Yeah.
It is right. Creativity. Right. And if you
don't keep it moving. Yeah. And flowing.
Yeah. I always feel like that. Yeah.
I always take too long and
don't write some music.
It becomes very hard to kickstart it and
get it going again towards going to be
a level I'll, I'll be acceptable on.
That's why I buy mannequins. Yeah.
That's how to do it. Brian, have you ever
read the war of art? I don't think I am.
Great Book About Killing Procrastination,
about making you right. Making you, uh,
get, get shit done or do heart sounds
like something I'd like to read.
It's a really good small short
book. It's, it's per people,
even people that aren't
artists, it'll, um,
it'll get you motivated to just get shit
done that you've been procrastinating.
The way the guy puts it.
It's really,
he says his name is Steven Pressfield
and he wrote a, a bunch of books.
He's a pretty famous author, a lot of
like historical novels and stuff. I think,
I believe he's a famous for,
but he's,
uh, he's also famous for being like really
prolific and he's super honest and I
spoke about how he was a fucking loser
up until he was like 40 years old.
And it just like, he couldn't, couldn't
fucking get it together. It couldn't work.
He couldn't just,
and he's,
he just kept failing and then finally
figured out how to just become a
professional, how to really become
a professional and fucking work.
And when he did that, everything
changed. Completely changed.
And he's like super honest about it
and super honest about, um, what, what,
what holds you back? The
resistance. He calls it resistance,
like the lazy procrastination,
all the self destructive shit that
people do to avoid doing things that they
know that they should do.
And the way he puts it is really
a quite brilliant and it's a very,
it's very inspirational. Book. It real
small too. If you're not a big reader,
the war of art, we'll get you cause it's
nice and small. Um, thanks everybody man.
Thank you. Everlast thank you. Always
come back again. Anytime we're going to,
we're going to have to do
more of these problems.
I think we'll have to move to do at least
three a week. And you need to do like,
you know,
even like I said,
bringing somebody in to the mix and now
don't want to meet some of these cats,
man and fans of somebody to do.
You tell me anytime I got somebody
that you want to, come on, man,
you got a ticket always. I've got a
few folks that want to come on to what?
I'll tell you gotta make
some Shit happen folks.
We're gonna make some shit
happen. All right? Yes. See
you heard it all here folks.
Uh, thanks everybody. Thanks to the
flashlight. Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and enter
in the code name. Rogan.
Save yourself some money on
your new jerk off toy. I use it.
It's fucking wonderful.
Nice. My wife actually said,
that sounds like something that's cool.
Like if you're going to jerk off
shore, that was like, you're crazy.
It's way better than the regular
masturbation. It's fucking solid product.
And it's the first one for
men that supposedly was
really good for a long time.
It's really hard. I've got some questions.
Can I ask them real quick? Sure.
We have time. Is it
disposable or chart? Yeah,
but you're going to throw his
weight. Jeans, man. I'm saying
these things you get like a certain amount
of uses out or is it clean it after a
while. You kind of want to
probably get a new one now.
I in my opinions cause I mean
I fucked the shit out of him.
I don't want to fuck them anymore.
Brian's a savage though. He fucked.
He shoves it in corners of couches
and fucking assaulted. He's a,
he's an animal man. Right?
The fucks like a while now.
I'm gonna say it has a lot of blood
stains on. Yeah. You look at him, man.
He's very deceptive. He's
quite violent and sexuality. I,
I've been scared of him since I met him.
Thanks to audit the microphone.
Sound good man. I mean, I think it's a
really good thing. No training either.
This fucking crazy bastard.
Uh, on at.com, o n n I, t,
makers of a Alpha brain, new mood,
shroom tech sport and trim tech and me.
And go check it out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com enter in the
code and the Rogan and you save yourself
10% off all orders, not just your first
order. All right. You dirty bitches.
Uh, we will be back at least once
this week, most like twice, uh,
whilst likely twice a Jim
Jeffries is going to be here
on Friday. And, uh, I think
we're gonna have one, uh, before
Friday, probably Wednesday,
maybe with me friend Dom, I rare,
uh, if I can talk him into it.
One of my favorite old school
comics and a, a great, great, great,
great friend of mine and a brilliant
comedian, Jeff Dahmer Railroad.
Hopefully we'll get him on all you
dirty freaks. I'll see you soon.
We love you very much. And, uh,
you know the fucking drill. So yes.
[inaudible].